welcome everybody to this uh special
podcast Town Hall Hybrid event we are
here in De Moine Iowa it's going to be a
whole lot of fun we got we got big news
in politics today Chris Christie has
dropped out of the race and was caught
on a hot mic so this story is pretty
wild and we'll definitely talk about
that because there is an interesting uh
uh bit of information coming out Chris
Chrissy said that Rhonda santz gave him
a phone call and was petrified that he
was going to and then he stops right
there and then someone else says to him
that Ron may get out of the race after
Iowa which would be really really
interesting considering there's so very
few people left but today we're going to
go over some of the big stories in uh uh
in the news and in this country over the
past several several years which have
bubbled up into this very serious
presidential election cycle and of
course we are hanging out with some
really awesome people the first thing I
want to do is give a shout out to based
records they produce awesome music they
are helping build the parallel economy
and they've helped sponsor this event to
make it all possible possible you've got
Chad PRS I'd be jolly too check out that
song You've Got High reses triggered and
ain't no rock and roll from five times
August we're big fans of these guys
they've all been on timcast iral before
seriously Bas records.com thank you guys
so much for help make this event
possible also become a member at
timcast.net
going man it's good to be here man with
our live studio audience in Iowa welcome
audience we got a bunch of people
hanging out love these guys love my Ians
right now now for the people who don't
know you here how would you introduce
yourself I'm kiding I think uh I think
we spent a lot of time here in Iowa but
uh VI people have really gotten their
pronunciation down over the course of
this campaign if there's one thing that
we've gotten out of this campaign people
have really understood how to rhyme
something with cake yeah yeah we have we
have so many people on the show and
we'll be like it's Viv and they'll go oh
yeah sorry good we also have Candace
Owens hanging out whoop whoop of course
my Applause what's up Candace a live
studio Applause you got to get it up on
the mic can you hear me better now oh
yeah yeah lowsky of course was already
talking yeah hell yeah welcome back
beautiful and amazing human beings of
Iowa let's hear it from the crowd here I
think it's going to be a really awesome
incredible show the conversation
definitely is going to be uh spicy I
think to say the least when everyone
here as there's a lot of crazy things to
talk about in 2024 that is already
shaping up to be one hell of a year and
I think it's fair to say it's only going
to get crazier from here yeah man deep
fakes it's going to be so wild you guys
this this ride is this a simulation are
we in some sort of czy is actually the
answer dud was intending to make the
show as crazy as possible let's go deep
what's up everybody hello looking good
in the house so uh the first thing I'd
like to do because this is a special
episode we're going to be talking about
a lot of things pertaining to this
election cycle is uh you know I'm going
to call out V ramaswami right here in
front of all of these big fans of yours
because you said in a CNN Town Hall that
it's beginning to look I'm paraphrasing
but it's beginning to look like January
6 was an inside job and I must call you
out sir because I will tell you
definitively it was an inside job and uh
the media of course criticize you for
pushing conspiracy theories they're
lying they uh uh I want to call the
media specifically first and foremost a
handful of media Outlets many of whom
may actually be in the room today and so
uh no disrespect to the individuals I
know these people aren't the ones who
wrote the stories but I I I the first
thing I have for everybody is the
definition of inside job from Oxford
languages an inside job is defined as a
crime committed by or with the
assistance of a person living or working
on the premises where it occurred that's
simple right like some guy Robs a Bank
and a security guard opens the door to
let him in that's the assistance that's
an inside job how about that I also just
for good measure got the definition from
Miriam Webster just to just to be sure
and it once again says something very
similar done by or with the help of
someone in a position or within an
organization or group so I got a
question let let me go through these
stories real quick so we have this from
CNN factchecking the vamas Swami CNN
Town Hall where they say a false claim
that police rolled out the red carpet on
January 6 they go on to say that you
said it was an inside job they say facts
first ramas Swami's claim that the
riters were invited into the capital is
false about 140 police officers were
assaulted while trying to stop the mob
from breaching the capital etc etc this
is a trick that many in media do where
they will take a a true statement a fact
then try to apply it to a totally
different set of facts is it true that
police officers were injured yes it is
is it also true that police opened the
doors and fanned people in yes it is
here's a story from cnn.com that I will
use to debunk CNN.com man who said
January 6 was magical acquitted in US
capital Riot case where they say a
federal judge on Wednesday found Matthew
Martin not guilty of four Federal
misdemeanors related to trespassing
Martin who worked for a government
contractor before his arrest following
the riot successfully argued that a US
capital police officer waved him into
the building at Le at least one video
played during the trial appeared to show
an officer moving his arm in a waving
motion yeah CNN really doesn't want to
admit it but let's break down the facts
here a judge determined a police officer
made a waving motion thus a man who
entered the building felt he was invited
and thus there were no criminal charges
to be had the case was dismissed if the
police officer assisted that man would
that not be an inside job according to
Oxford here's an article from CNN Joe
Scarboro lambas Capital police you
opened the effing doors for them going
to say that they politely opened the
doors for terrorists who had scrawled
into door murder the media if the police
politely opened the doors providing
assistance to these people to come in
would that not be an inside job and how
about this one from the New York Post
January 6 footage shows Capital cops
escorting qan Shaman to senate floor so
I I I have to just simply say when we
say something like it was an inside job
or it appears to be they'll immediately
respond by saying what's your proof that
the Biden Administration did it well I
never said that I said it was inside job
the capital police were taking selfies
with people in some instances open the
doors and let people in I'm glad to have
called out these uh news organizations
first and foremost NBC news of course
the vras Swami promotes January 6
conspiracy theory by suggesting it was
an inside job I think according to CNN's
own reporting as well as the Oxford
definition we've here definitively
stated and proven it was an inside job
my question is if the people inside are
under duress and they let the the people
outside in because they're afraid for
their lives are is it still technically
an inside job or was it provoked by the
Crow's you know fear essence of fear
it's a bit I I kind of lie with you that
I think it is still technically you know
neutrally an inside you're also assuming
that that was the case right I mean I
think that's even under that most
charitable
interpretation those aren't necessarily
the same people you're talking about
thousands of people so some people had
some violent Behavior outside different
people who show up at a door are allowed
in in a friendly manner from the
standpoint of the person who was allowed
in it doesn't matter what Circumstance
the police officer was under the
question is what do they believe the
government is telling them so from the
standpoint of that defendant I'm a guy
who walks up to the house of the people
wants to walk in take my iPhone around
you see many of those people okay
probably the first time in the Capitol
building and they were allowed in by a
federal police officer that are the
Capitol Police now I find weeks or
months or a year and a half later I'm
part of the largest Manhunt in modern
American history to be put into prison
in many cases
charged held without even being charged
so I think at the level of the
individual Jewel this is what it comes
down to it's not about finding what
circumstance was or wasn't
understandable for the government for
somebody who's going to be locked up we
better darn well apply the highest
standard of a burden of proof to say
that's what we're going to apply before
you lock you up and so the Capitol
Police initially were sitting on a lot
of that footage they said it's sat with
Congress so many of those defendants
were charged without getting access to
that video footage and again the
justification they made was you know
usually a prosecutor has to turn over
exculpatory evidence to a defendant but
here they didn't do it because they said
Congress technically has the tapes and
that's not the prosecutors of the
doj again from the standpoint of an
individual defendant it doesn't matter
it's the government that's coming after
you to put you in prison and if the
government's going to come after you to
put you in prison couple basic things
have to be true that government did not
actually cause you or incite you to
commit the crime and we're just talking
about the capital police dimension of
this let alone the FBI Dimension and the
other thing that has to be true is you
have a chance to defend yourself with
full exculpatory evidence including the
video footage of the circumstances of
you being allowed into that very
building you were allegedly trespassing
it if neither of those things were the
case then I think that that's not a
crime and anybody who has been convicted
or pressured into a false plea deal
under those circumstances will on my
watch get a pardon on day one because
that's the right thing to do to stand
for the rule of law in this country
would you retry them with the New
Evidence I think that it would depend on
the circum IR ances but when you think
about somebody who was first of all
peacefully protesting that day and
allowed in in those circumstances
there's something bigger going on here
in that same year we've applied a
totally different standard of the rule
of law to Violent riots I'm not going to
call them mostly peaceful protests it's
a translation if you're decoding the
media lingo on this one mostly peaceful
protest in the year 2020 FR antifa or
BLM refers to Violent riots against the
backdrop of a year where there were all
kinds of peaceful to Violent riots
across this country and so against that
backdrop I believe especially what these
people have been put through already
this is years of hell that we've put
citizens of this country through anybody
who was peaceful and did not physically
assault somebody that day will get a day
one pardon from me and then I'm going to
go down the list even of the people who
allegedly right I don't believe anymore
the government they just said you're
violent as an allegation now let's get
to the facts and go down the list
anybody else who had their
constitutional rights denied during that
process will also in addition get a
pardon I can't commit to that on day one
but on day one I commit to start the
process of going Case by case and it's
not even about those defendants
individually though that matters of
course to me it's about the future of
this country because if we put ourselves
in a position where they can go after
political opponents for this reason they
can go after political opponents for any
reason you got Julian Assange rotting in
a foreign prison while the person who
leaked to Julian nange is a Woman by the
name of Chelsea Manning who effectively
got her sentence Comm by President Obama
because she's transgender I actually
have increasingly concluded she's
probably not even transgender she's
probably just smart knowing that that's
how how you have to identify to be a
member of a politically favorable class
and so the two standards of the rule of
law are really what irk me the most and
so this isn't just for the people who
are there on January 6th it's for the
rest of us in this country as well and
so I don't think retrial for most of
those cases is the right answer if
you're peaceful protester on January 6
you were truly peaceful and you were
convicted or forced to plead or coerced
to plead under false false pretenses you
will get a pardon on day one when I'm in
office I want to bring up real quick
just uh uh to highlight again what CNN
said in their article fact cheing you
when they said about 140 police officers
were assaulted while trying to stop the
mob from breaching the
capital it's it's it's not shocking that
almost every single news story that we
hear about January 6 involves those who
are acting
violently but I think perhaps one thing
that we can do better especially uh you
know we've got scanner.com sr.com we we
have a news team is focus on those who
were peaceful nonviolent and shut up
after the fact I met a a a woman at a
restaurant and this is in the Maryland
area she went down to DC with her
husband they said this is a story she
told me she showed up an hour and a half
or so after the riding had already
concluded and people were actually
leaving she walks up to the Capitol
building with open sidewalks there's
people standing on the grass talking
there's people walking around the doors
are wide open her and her husband walk
up see people and the police standing
there walk on walking around she said
for a few minutes asked what was going
on they said nothing much and said Okay
and she left she was sentenced to 18
months in jail they the court did not
care that she was non-violent that she
was just a tourist who went to see
Donald Trump speak was unaware of any
barricades I think the issue is
especially for the corporate press those
stories aren't newsworthy for them
they're not going to get clicks if you
take a look at how CNN reported the
acquittal of Matthew Martin they still
just don't want to admit that a police
officer waved a man into the building
and a judge agreed he was welcomed in
they still try and make it seem like
it's all a misunderstanding and the cop
wasn't waving him in yeah and and you
know what the corporate press piece is
interesting of this cuz some of the
people who are now they're now going
after there were members of the press
that day in the field covering it as
members of the press but if they're part
of the corporate press somehow that was
immune from investigation you have
independent journalists who are actually
documenting what was happening are the
ones that the Justice Department's now
going after got the likes of Owen
Shroyer who was actually yelling as best
I know it didn't even go in the capital
was on a megaphone yelling 1776 I didn't
think that was a crime in this country
but apparently that was by definition
they and he ended up spending time
actually unfortunately under prosecution
and under conviction so I think it's a
violation of the rule of law I also
think you haven't even gotten to the to
the spicy stuff but first of all I want
to say one thing I'm glad that CNN you
know at least took the approach they did
it otherwise we wouldn't be here doing
this actually probably you know CNN I
did a town hall here in Iowa about about
maybe month and a half ago where we
started to talk to this woman uh Abby
Phillips who was moderating the town
hall they literally cut it off 5 minutes
early like ler was supposed to be there
a fulltime there's a full run of show by
the time I start talking about January
6th and there's only a few third rails
that you really can't touch but for
whatever reason this is one of them they
end the whole thing five minutes ear
Trot out a bunch of different experts
explaining to Their audience why
everything they just heard was
misinformation and needed to be debunked
as dangerous for the future and then
that's when they start calling us and
and you know they actually uh on YouTube
funny thing is they threatened us with
the cease and desist for putting up that
town hall while Nikki Haley still sat up
there for six months I think part of it
is Tim it's not just that it's less
spicy for Less clicks I think there's
something deeper and more ideological
definitely going on here that they
believe it is their responsibility to
make sure the public does not hear what
in this case hear are the facts of what
happened but even in other cases
viewpoints that are alternative to their
own I do think that's an important part
of what's going on at the levels of
these organizations well this is the
thing we don't know a lot of the facts
how many FBI agents played a role in
what happened how many undercover police
officers or other federal agencies
participated in this event why did it
take so long to respond what just
happened to Ray EPs and how was he able
to get that kind of deal when there's so
many people rotting away in solitary
confinement right now and you don't even
have to go as far as to say it was an
inside job or it wasn't an inside job
the burden of proof is on the government
the people have questions we should
demand answers and I think we need a
full investigation not just of that
event but the entire FBI from from its
Inception they have been doing illegal
horrible things to the American public
lying spying destroying people's
personal lives blackmailing individuals
including MLK and more importantly when
you look at what what happened
specifically in 2001 in in New York City
the FBI also played a major role in that
incident that they were never held
accountable for we need a full
investigation into the FBI would that be
something that you would support yes but
I think I have gained enough of an
understanding of the FBI such that I can
confidently say the correct answer is
not to give them some new building or
anything else it is not to replace
Christopher Ray which is just a which is
just a fake Mirage get Christopher Ray
out you get James Comey 2.0 I'm
convinced the right answer is to shut
down the failed Bureau of Investigation
the FBI that's the only answer that
remains and I actually think you guys
are
you know playing almost nicer with
respect to the facts that we do have as
I said you know I agree that it appears
to be an inside job but we don't really
know the full extent of what happened I
will say though it's interesting I don't
know if you guys have talked about this
in the show before I've kind of gone
deep on this because I think it's
important not just for this incident but
for the future of the country you know
who the Detroit field office head was at
the time of the alleged Gretchen Whitmer
kidnapping plot are you guys is
something you've talked about before or
not
really
yeah this is this is important though to
understand the Nexus it's kind of an
underbelly in our law enforcement so the
Gretchen Whitmer kidnapping plot
actually began as a plot to storm the
capital in the state of Michigan and you
know how started it started was people
at the FBI putting people up to this
poor guys one of them was actually
supposedly getting hot water from a
Mexican restaurant across the street
these are people who are not doing well
in their life who they've put up and
cultivated with $5,000 credit cards with
$5,000 limits to go by Munitions and
otherwise to initially what began is a
plot to storm the capital but eventually
ended up being a plot to kidnap Gretchen
Whitmer a good number of the people who
were captured here like we're talking
about a high proportion of them were
absolutely Federal informant and yet the
Detroit field office head and they took
that all the way to trial several of the
people at trial were con were acquitted
on grounds of entrapment one of the
jurors at the end went to one of the
defendants just gave him a hug and
apologized for what he had been through
because the juror actually had to see
what the FBI put these people up to and
you can't make this stuff up in October
of 2020 3 months before January of
2021 guess who gets a promotion to be
the DC field office head was none other
than that Detroit field office head and
what do you have on January 6 2021 3
months later is a storming of the US
capital so there's a lot here that
suggests I mean the DC pipe bomb story
at the DNC and the RNC headquarters why
haven't we heard the first thing about
what we actually know despite the
existence of video footage about that
and the careful coinciden of exactly
when that pipe bomb at the RNC
headquarters happened to have been
discovered with the timer on it down to
the time where the actual vote was
supposed to be cast for certifying the
results of the election it's it's just
an impossibility that was the number one
thing for me I mean yeah the day after
and started to cut you off but the day
after January 6th I was like this is
it's complete set up by the FBI I mean
if you mean to tell me that I was living
in Washington DC at the time a couple of
blocks away from the White House when
January 6th happened it was very bizarre
day because we had an entire summer of
people rioting it was scary to go
outside I was pregnant at the time uh
cars set on fire every day there was a a
crazy protest people storming buildings
at all times suddenly after the Summer
of Love BLM we were getting phone calls
people asking if we were okay after
January 6 when there wasn't any any
sounds outside of where I lived if you
mean to tell me that in Washington DC
where you can't walk 2 feet it is the
most surveilled building in the world
okay that a couple of blocks away from
the White House they can't figure out
where there again cameras on every
single Corner every inch who got out of
their car placed pipe bombs at the RNC
and the DNC headquarters and went away
and let me tell you how extensive their
church was this is something that people
are not talking about because you you're
talking about people that stood trial
and of course that's the most important
the people that are being locked up
people that have committed suicide let's
not forget to talk about people that
have killed themselves for fear of being
locked up because they showed up to
support the sitting president of the
United States I have two friends from
Stanford Connecticut who showed up to
hear Donald Trump speak and went home
okay that was it they never went into
the capital building nothing after the
speech they didn't go up FBI agents
showed up at their house this was a
harassment and intimidation campaign
that took place if you even showed up to
support president Trump they got
questioned they got questioned they were
they found a picture of them on Facebook
with a Maga flag they heard Trump speak
and they went home and these people were
questioned by the feds so they had
enough resources right to send them out
and hunt down people that were posting
pictures but they can't find out who
just tried to blow up headquarters in
Washington DC a couple of blocks away
from the White House and you want to
know what the weirdest part about this
is and I'm just as I go deeper learning
facts about this is kamla Harris the
number two for better worse to to
succeed the US president was at the DNC
headquarters that
morning with all com me the level of
security there that understand and
suddenly they randomly they just see it
in a park bench later so I think there's
enough facts here to know the government
has not been transparent with us but
furthermore we know Capital police
officers let him in we know that the
video footage was success was
selectively released such that you did
not see shooting rubber bullets and tear
gas into the mostly peaceful crowd you
saw the reaction of those people hitting
the capital after releasing that and
then you did not see initially Capital
police officers allowing peaceful in
people in peacefully it's a distortion
and we just deserve the truth well I
have I have a question for you so I've
I've often talked about the May 29th
Insurrection May 29th 2020 thousands of
far-left extremists stormed the
barricades of the White House fought
with hundreds if not uh several hundred
police officers injuring around between
70 and 140 they firebombed the White
House grounds that's true they they set
fire to a guard Tower and they set fire
to St John's Church this is the
historical church the founding fathers
would go to it was so severe that the
president was forced into his emergency
bunker thus disrupting His official
duties and really yes wow and my
question is why where was our commission
where where was the uh I mean the photos
of that day when uh you know I go to
family gatherings over the holidays and
I show a photo of an aerial shot of DC
which many of you may have seen smoke
rising out all around the White House in
the surrounding areas from fires that
were being lit the president was forced
into an emergency bunker against his
will and the media made fun of him and
called him bun ER boy for having had to
experience this Donald Trump said I I
went down they they showed me he clearly
didn't want to be there when law
enforcement then cleared out the
extremists who had laid Siege to the
White House I'm being purposefully
hyperbolic you understand why Donald
Trump came out the next day and took a
picture and they attacked him and
insulted him for having defended the
White House and a church that was set on
fire by extrem an extremist faction a
faction so extreme in fact that similar
groups and and cells within the same
ideology had seized several blocks in
various cities in Atlanta in Seattle in
their their Capitol Hill occupation and
in Minnesota with George Floy Square
yeah videos emerged out of I believe it
was Seattle of armed groups walking
around with AR-15s pointing them at
drivers people of a similar or same
ideology in fact many of these people do
coordinate yep engaged in Insurrection
now of course we can calm down and say a
bunch of extremist activists riding in
the streets no Insurrection oh Fair
Point that neither was the capital well
what about Bret Kavanaugh does anybody
lie for the BR Cavanaugh hearings do you
remember them storming in going into
Senators offices do like I mean I'm
telling you DC was insane and nobody
cared until January 6th happened this
was like a routine thing that was
happening to get their ideas across they
were doing sit-ins they were walking in
you know in the Halls Uninvited they
couldn't get these people out I mean it
it's just crazy to think that suddenly
they focused on January 6th and it's
hard to imagine that the feds were not
in on it when we know we have all of
these pieces of footage
right at the very least one one thing
because I think there's two strands here
both are interest there's I think
there's two different points and both
are interesting but I think it's
important not to make some up because it
might risk us missing the real plot here
which is one is did we have we applied
the different standard of rule of law
throughout this country over the course
of 2020 absolutely we did antifa BLM you
name it if you have a leftwing ideology
was mostly peaceful protest you ignore
it that's that's a glaring point and
deserves to be called out and I think
that there can be no justice with two
standards of the rule of law based on
your political
ideology I think to be clear what
happened on January 6th was not some
small joke this was significant in terms
of the number of people terms of you
mean some of the video footage the
mainstream media picked out but I think
what's significant about it is we don't
know what actually caused those people
to act the way they they did was it
really the government instigating
something that otherwise didn't exist
using it as a deflection to achieve a
national security States Revival that
had otherwise receded over the course of
20 years since the post 911 period And
so maybe I've just told you what I
actually think is going on here but
that's what I think the facts suggest is
there was a reason to for these people
to not only get Donald Trump out of
office but to discredit this to relegate
this line of thinking the movement
behind him to the dust bins of history
and this was the way to do it so I think
that there was a lot of depth to this
and it wasn't just that okay well like
this was I mean these are two two
different standards of two different bad
things yes but this was I think a very
serious
forethought exercise in accomplishing
something and unless we see through it
first step when you see a problem is to
name it unless we do that they are going
to accomplish what they set out to
accomplish that's what I believe I'd
like to jump to some breaking news from
today and then we'll get into some core
issues that are happening we've got
stories on immigration there was a
school in New York that they they they
told the kids to go remote you can't use
a school anymore because illegal
immigrants are coming in we have a
breaking story from James O'Keefe where
he actually track down buses engaged in
human trafficking and they flee from it
it's really interesting but we'll start
with this story from our good friends at
the New York Times Christy caught on hot
mik disparaging Haley and DeSantis now
the interesting thing here is of course
that he dropped out but we also have
this hot mic moment I want to play and
get your thoughts on uh hopefully this
will this play properly I I mean I hope
so let's play
it I can hear it down here is there a
way to get it to play on the
speakers there is no way to get it to
play on the speakers not right now I
can't even hear it on the
headphones okay well we can't play it
unfortunately we know what he said yeah
I I've heard it we've heard it heard
we've all heard it so I want to clarify
some things because in the tweet that
went initial that started getting a lot
of play it's got half a million so far
it says Chris chrisy says Nikki Haley is
quote Gonna Get Smoked and you and I
both know it she's not up to this in
regards to Trump Christy says Ronda
santis called him up petrified now what
Christy says is Ron called me petrified
that I was gonna or something like that
and then cuts off someone else that
intervenes and says he's probably
getting out after
Iowa I personally do not believe Ron
drops out after Iowa but I'm curious
there's a few things Candace you
actually made a really good point about
this if you want to so when I was
sitting down and I I think I actually
said this on my podcast but during the
the first Republican
debates it was the energy going into it
was essentially that Dan santis was
going to have to come out and say stuff
against V obviously because V was having
a surge in the polls and interestingly
enough he didn't say anything to vake
but then suddenly Chris Christie just
went like an attack dog um and I just
thought it was really odd I was like
this feels strangely coordinated to me I
feel like Chris Christie and Ronda
santis are maybe friends and they're all
friends and they all know that this is
the guy they have to attack I felt this
I said this in my podcast and then I
thought it was really interesting that
Dan sanas called him petrified about
whatever it is I just thought to myself
why is D santis calling Chris Christie
at all do they have a relationship again
these are just questions we probably are
not going to get the answer to them as
they're already working on a spin and
saying that as sanis was just calling to
you know bid him farewell from the race
or something yeah s was petrified that
Christie would do something we don't
know what he was going to do but that's
according to Chris Christie I'm curious
as to why they were in conversation at
all and why did would Express to him his
his fear over something Christie might
do I haven't talked to either today I
can tell you that
so so I'll tell you something I think
that there's something deeper going on
and this is today a footnote
it's a footnote but a footnote in the
deeper game that's hiding in plain sight
I think I you said oh is this all just
one giant deep fake I actually think it
is yeah actually I think we're
witnessing a deep fake in real time and
the Deep fake is this and and the people
who are the subjects to it I think every
one of the people who is the subject to
It For Better or Worse is falling for
the Deep fake which is that this system
the system has made a decision the same
one that they thought they were making
back when Donald Trump was exiting
office okay they didn't get right that
time around to make a decision that this
man shall not be allowed anywhere near
the White House again period they will
stop at nothing and at this point I I
really mean nothing to keep this man out
of the White House so what are they
trying to do I was trying to figure out
for a long time it didn't feel like it
was going to be a Trump versus Biden
race there's a lot with Biden you got
the documents case coming out why are
they tring that against Biden after like
10 years Hunter Biden okay we could have
talked about it now suddenly it's
gaining credibility didn't feel like it
was going to be Biden so I think
incorrectly assumed that it was was
going to be Gavin Newsome or somebody
else this the new puppet other than
Biden they want to trot out and I think
what became increasingly clear is that
they've actually found a much more
convenient new puppet a puppet who
actually can give them a lot of air
cover by being within the Republican
party or the guys of the Republican
Party itself and that's Nikki Haley of
course the very people who are paying to
keep Trump off the ballot in lawsuits
like Reed Hoffman the founder of
LinkedIn or even Larry fin the king of
the woke industrial complex the leader
of Black Rock look at who they're
supporting it's not new it's not Joe
Biden it's Nikki Haley actually and so
what they want to do to put in plain
sight is to make this a two horse race
between Donald Trump and a puppet who
they can control I believe that's Nikki
Haley eliminate Trump from
contention and then Trot in their
controllable puppet into the White House
that's the game that's hiding in plain
sight and I think everybody's falling
for it actually I don't think they're
falling for it I I think it's very it's
odd every time we look at the polls or
the the news organizations they keep
telling us Nikki is surging and it's so
obvious if you speak to people that
she's not after every single debate
they're like Nikki won Nikki won even
when it's so she's not even third place
in terms of who won and they're trying
to convince us it's a full propaganda
effort when it comes to Nikki Haley and
you're right um it's pretty Sinister
what they're doing but the people I
don't think are falling for the only
part that I'm worried the people are
falling for is some idea that this
system is literally going to somehow
stop short of literally stopping at
nothing to keep Donald Trump away from
the White House you think is it Trump or
is it the what he represents the
methodologies that he's used like
canceling the transpacific partnership
kind of isolationist mentality I think
the third rails there are definitely
foreign policy I think ending the war in
Ukraine on the terms that either I or
Trump have suggested definitely hits the
third rail I think the preservation of
the National Security State is a third
rail those are the two big ones the
preservation of the National Security
bureaucracy at home you talk about the
anti-woke stuff the transgender stuff
yeah I mean we have disagreements on the
partisan basis but that's all fine it's
mostly a deflection actually it's almost
a convenient fact that Nikki Hal
occasionally gets to say things that pay
homage to the anti-woke movement I don't
think she has actual beliefs but at
least it's part of the cover the real
third rails are foreign policy keep the
interventionist neoliberal
neoconservative worldview of the us as
the hamon that actually gets people to
cut in on the rake here at home the
likes of the John boltons and the Nikki
Haley right and then third rail is the
National Security State at home but I
think in Donald Trump's case I think
that they've they've convinced
themselves that with this man in
particular he is so d ous to the Future
he's demonstrated himself to be their
words you know their their view not mine
that they have to and have a moral duty
to this country and when you believe you
have a moral duty to do something then
you're bound by your more subordinate
moral constraints because there's the
everyday Mor moral Norms you operate
against but if you think it's about the
future existence of humanity or a nation
then those ordinary constraints no
longer apply and I think that's the mode
the system is now in the ordinary
constraints are okay you let people on a
ballot not anymore you don't prosecute
people for madeup crimes especially in
the middle of a presidential election
not anymore and if they've ratchet it up
each of those times and none of those
things work I just think eventually
they're just going to stop at nothing
whatever it takes to take Trump out
after they've narrowed it down to a
two-horse race between Trump and Haley
which in turn is why I'm in this till
the very end and I think that we have a
responsibility to this
country to make sure that that plot
doesn't play out they're selling us the
Rope today that they'll use to hang us
tomorrow that's what's happening and I
don't want people in in our movement to
fall for the other part of this to
somehow think that that actually isn't
going to be successfully executed this
uh this hot mic moment where someone
mutters Ron's probably getting out after
Iowa let's imagine the scenario that Ron
actually decides for whatever happens in
Iowa his showing wasn't good enough and
it's time to end this race the worst
possible thing imaginable would be you
then leaving the race as well because it
would by default give us either Trump or
Haley and I'm definitely not exactly for
that reason that's a nightmare scenario
but you know look I think you know I
mean I have my own views I think we're
going to deliver a major surprise here
in Iowa we can talk about that
separately I think we're going to shock
the system and The Vibes on the ground
are very good but as part of the 50,000
foot view here I actually think if you
play this out intuitively it feels like
the next step in the game among the
corporate candidates is Ron would make a
good vice president for Nikki right
chrisy out of the way is one foot note
today all right eliminate part of the
consolidation in New Hampshire Christie
is not running for president of the
United States ever he was arguably
running for like vice president of New
Hampshire but anyway once he exited
we'll actually combine that in to prop
up Nikki a little bit more the next
thing is you take the Ronda santis Ronda
s is not in New Hampshire so much but in
certain other states Florida or
otherwise turn that over as well to the
anti-trump movement I don't think Ron
knows that I think if people ask Ron de
santis he would say of course I would
not be Nikki's vice president and I
think inside him he probably would
believe that that's actually what he
thinks but that almost pretends that
what he thinks actually matters his
donors are the ones that put him up to
run for president in the first place I
don't think the man on his own own
valtion I think there are other people
who put him up to run for president at a
time where it didn't make for sense for
him to do it the same people are going
to put him up to be Nikki's vice
president so you play this forward
that's where this goes final step take
Trump out of contention Trot the
corporate puppets into office that's
where this plot ends and I feel like I
see this with a level of clarity that
makes it torturous it's like a kind of
form of torture to watch this playing
out in real time without standing up and
actually doing something about let let
me real real quick just to get in there
scenario Donald Trump wins the primary
he said he he he comes right on out and
says V ramaswami you are my vice
president what do you say Donald Trump
wins the you're saying Donald Trump wins
the primary and then that so I think we
just have to have an honest conversation
I mean if if that's the scenario we're
in that's not what I'm playing for but
if that's what we're in I have an
inconvenient attribute which is that I
have opinions I have strong opinions
about things I'm not somebody who really
you know rolls over or whatever but what
I've said is Donald Trump has my full
support if he's the nominee and I expect
his full support if I'm the nominee but
I don't think we get to that place
that's the whole premise of of I mean
when you think it's Gavin Newsome or Joe
Biden is the puppet you think you might
get to that place I don't think they
want Biden or Nome I think Nikki is a
far more Reliable Pawn for the system
with respect to the two things they care
about most which is keeping the foreign
war machine humming far more reliable on
places from the Middle East to Ukraine
she's far more hawkish than actually
anybody in the Democratic side and with
respect to the National Security State I
don't think Joe Biden could have come up
with the idea if he tried to tie every
social media account and internet
account with a government issued ID so I
don't think it goes there Tim I think
where it goes is they want this laid in
the primary and then they get the air
cover because the Democratic party's
brand isn't doing too hot the permanent
state is fundamentally nonpartisan at
its core so they get the air cover of
saying oh yeah we weren't even we
weren't even doing the Democrat game
with where most of the Republican Bas
watching cable news thinks it's about
beating Biden they're missing the plot
that's what's going on that's actually a
really great point we were talking just
the other day there was a story of JP
Morgan top Str strategist I'm sure you
heard said his prediction is that Joe
Biden drops out just after super Tuesday
due to a health issue I view that as a
very very good strategy for Democrats I
had been saying for some time that I
believe Joe Biden will drop out his
health is just not there his polling is
not there it is political suicide
however many people pointed out in our
chats and in our audience that it's too
late to have a primary there's nothing
they can do actually that sounds like
the best play Joe Biden says I'm running
no primary to be had don't worry about
it come March he says oh no my aing
heart this gives the DNC the ability to
just appoint who is going to be their
nominee however I think you actually
make a much better Point why even worry
about going into a political conflict
with Donald Trump and the and and the
populist Republican base yes when you
can win from within haly and that's
exactly what's going on and also they
have they have this alien K Harris
problem because if anything other than K
Harris is the nominee then they got the
racist you know misogynist thing going
on which underly which undermines their
own self stated narrative and I think
just the brand of the democratic party
for the Larry thinks or the
establishment Puppet Masters of the
world it's a little tarnished right now
let them heal themselves we're going to
do this within the Republican party with
a much more reliable vessel with a
little bit more of a polished exterior a
little bit more committed on the proar
agenda and a lot more committed on the
censorship and and National Security
agenda here at home I think that
actually gets their job done much better
without some of the inconveniences that
come with Biden so like you I was
initially of the mind that you know who
are they going to trot out instead of
and nothing quite really the shoe didn't
really fit with any of them Michelle
Obama Gavin Newsome and then you see
it's just staring in plain sight they're
already halfway through doing it within
the Republican primary and then it's
game over and they get the air cover of
saying they weren't even propping up
Democrats that's what's going on let's
let's jump to some stories on some key
issues I have this tweet from James
O'Keefe this video was uh was pretty
shocking to watch there have been
reports about buses that have been
trafficking illegal immigrants in fact I
can say this as well I have personally
confirmed the existence of major airlin
boarding passes that state no name given
this was bro this story was broken uh by
Ashley stclair it uh we're still waiting
on on vetting and development so by all
means anyone in the Press who wants to
doubt this story you feel free to do so
but I will put my reputation on the line
and say I have reviewed the materials
it's more than just a boarding pass
saying no name given we've had our own
employees at timcast W uh witness on
these flights doing these events Planes
full of illegal immigrants carrying
these bags with instructions they don't
speak English someone is doing this and
it may be uh uh not just we we know the
Biden Administration has been
facilitating uh much of this we know
this because back in 2021 there was a
report about migrant children illegal
immigrant children being smuggled on
flights in the in the in the late hours
or the early hours of the morning into
places like Tennessee and Westchester
and uh we we from those stories and from
the expansion of them we also so we know
that exists we also know that yes Greg
Abbott and other Governors have been
sending illegal immigrants deeper into
the country in various places the
question is why is this happening why
isn't there uh why isn't our border
being secured why is it that when James
O'Keefe in this and this video is is
it's it's crazy they follow a bus
carrying these illegal immigrants the
bus tries to hit them the bus tries
fleeing and swerving through the road
going on and off exits trying to lose
them because journalists are following
them and then actually stops and does
not release its passengers and then
leaves again something about what
they're doing has them scared someone
will find out they're doing it but I'll
give you one quick story that happened
to me personally outside of this you
know Ashley stclair uh uh showed me the
materials it's a boarding pass that says
no name given do you want to board a a
major airliner with people our security
rtsa has no idea who these people are
where they come from I was in Chicago
over the holiday we flew on a private
jet how about that it's really fun isn't
it and our shuttle bus driver said the
other day a 737 came in and we were told
by our bosses that it was the Blackhawks
how fun does that oh you're going to
you're going to get to go service a
plane pull out the luggage for a famous
hockey team he said when they pulled up
to the plane and opened it up there were
three garbage bags in the forward uh uh
in the Ford cargo hold that's it no
luggage nothing they then found out that
the entire plane 140 passengers were
illegal immigrants and he said it was
Swift air I don't know that's what he
told me I asked him did they lie to you
claiming it was the Blackhawks because
you would not have served that plane had
you known you'd be facilitating illegal
immigration and he went Bingo exactly so
my question now is with all of this news
breaking and this is a massive story I'm
interested in your view on what's going
on I want to know how you plan to handle
it what you would do and I also want to
know your position on how do we handle
the fact that there are federal law
enforcement officers actually
facilitating this yeah well I think it's
again one of these when it was comes to
the media third rail issues when you
name what's going on so forget the
labels great replacement Theory whatever
just forget the labels what's going on
is what's the most parsimonious
explanation is there is a facilitation
of mass illegal migration into the
United States to secure lasting
electoral majorities for the Democratic
party and the reason you know that's not
a conspiracy theory is it is a
pre-stated strategy of Democrats dating
back to about 10 years ago and it's not
a surprised when you got mayorca sitting
by Joe Biden's side about 10 years ago
the guy who's actually running the
Department of Homeland Security right
now who is in turn refusing to enforce
the remaining Mexico policies yes that's
exactly what's going on and hiding in
plain sight and the math makes sense it
works so now you have AOC coming in for
cover in recent days what this was
yesterday or the day before saying that
actually the right solution isn't
building the wall but to document the
undocumented which is the next step to
them participating in those elections
and so it's if somebody tells you this
is what I'd like to do then they take
actions consistent with achieving what
they'd like to do and then consummate it
by actually doing that very thing and
changing in the composition of the
electorate and translating into who
actually ends up voting in elections you
tend to believe that that's the most
parsimonious explanation not something
else that we're otherwise struggling to
figure out how to solve well once we
figure out how to solve that we realize
it's not a technical problem right and
sometimes it's what bothers me in a lot
of the Border discussions is people get
into some sort of and I I've done this
too I'll get into technical details you
doing aquatic barriers in the Rio Grand
what do we think about the airlines how
should they be conforming the standards
to the other people that the TSA that
standing around as I call them at the
airport or or what are they doing none
of that
matters actually eliminate the intention
get the intentions in the right place
say Our intention is for people who
enter this country illegally to not be
in this country technically it becomes
actually a very easy challenge to solve
militarize the southern border we're
militarizing other people's borders how
about militarizing our own with our own
military militarize our border as we are
doing and should not be doing for others
use the Aquatic barriers in the r Grand
stop giving money to Central America
most of the people coming through Mexico
80% of them didn't start in Mexico
required each of those countries to
build a b border barricade all the way
from Venezuela to the southern border of
Texas and Birthright citizenship for
kids of illegals the 14th Amendment does
not apply to the kids of illegals I can
go to the legal argument on this they
duped Donald Trump on this one they said
you need a constitutional amendment
actually you don't stop Federal funding
for Sanctuary cities we're paying for
this our federal taxpayer money is
actually paying for this facilitation of
the domestic transfer to Sanctuary
cities and then anybody in this country
should be returned to their country of
origin if you're here illegally it's
that that simple now they say there's
only 6,000 ice agents immigrations and
Customs Enforcement
agents well again if you read the law
there's a section in the law I think
it's
287g or something like this that that
allows ice agents to serve their
warrants via local law enforcement you
just need again somebody running ideally
the entire executive branch of president
who tells the department of Home
Homeland Security and Ice to use that
authority to work with local law
enforcement now you got a million people
not just 6,000 to get the job done so I
gave you all of this as though the
technical challenge was really the
challenge it's not it's a challenge of
intention right now there's been a
long-standing intention to fundamentally
change the composition of the US
electorate if you call that a great
replacement Theory CNN will CN will have
a uh conniption if you say that you know
what this is part of an electoral
strategy they would ask you what's so
wrong with that but either way we got to
at least air what it actually is to be
able to have a debate whether this is
desirable policy or not but if you say
if you like it and if you support uh
people coming in and replacing the local
population you of course get promoted by
the corporate media yeah there's there's
there's crazy stats out there talking
about how there's more illegals brought
into the United States than actual
babies born inside of this country this
is to me the weaponization of human
trafficking the introduction of the
third world into the United States
that's going to create a super elitist
Uber class and a poor poverty everyone
else class this is far beyond just even
a great replacement this is this is
essentially the destruction of this
country from within how can we roll This
back how can we go back from hundreds of
thousands of people coming into this
country in such a weaponized millions of
people y well you can draft them into
the military I mean what send them to
Ukraine because the idea of mass Deport
deportations is like a storybook Nazi
Germany Vis like I can see the images of
like newly deputized ice agent like a
19-year-old cop going and like grabbing
some woman and pulling her out of her
house and her screaming as the babies
lying on the ground like the world will
not tolerate it even our own country as
much as I'm not saying that deportations
are are off the table but that's the
imagery that would be swung with
something like that so what you do send
them send them into the army go let them
earn their citizenship by fighting in
the Ukraine I don't know what the plan
is the only thing I would say about that
is one is I do favor in substance doing
this as humanely and respectfully as
possible in substance largely because
for many of these people it it's not
necessarily their fault right if you're
sitting in Honduras or wherever and you
got a US president and entire apparatus
that's giving you a wink and a nod to
come on over who knows maybe if many of
us were in their shoes we would have
done the same thing especially we're
parents of children who want better
lives for our children so I just think
it's the right thing to do for this
country because we're a nation founded
on the rule of law that's not something
that's necessarily hostile to most of
those millions are not otherwise
innately bad people but these are PE
regardless of whether they're good
people or bad people We're a nation
founded on the rule of law so I can't
with my level of sort of moral Clarity
on this I can't be a father of two sons
in the White House tell them they have
to follow the rules when I'm leading a
US government that actively isn't
following its own rules and so I think
as respectfully and humanely as possible
we have to return them to their country
of origin but there's a philosophical
Point here too which is I think once we
fall into the Trap as leaders
of trying to make decisions based on how
we fear they will be
portrayed then we're done making the
right decisions and we're just down the
road of actually dancing to what we
think we're going to be portrayed as and
it becomes circular whereas I think the
job of a good leader is to do what is
right and when the public does not agree
with you to persuade them of the fact
that that was still the right thing to
do I I do think the public are now very
aware of the problem that's happening
right now I'm I am totally comfortable
with Mass deportations I could
definitely stomach watching Mass
deportations happen I mean we've been
forced to stomach watching it happen the
other way I don't know if I'm broken on
the inside but I mean reading these
stories about people that you know can't
afford groceries and yet are having to
watch buses and schools emailing them
saying hey don't come in today because
we've decided to give the school that
you've been funding for years with your
tax dollars to illegal immigrants so
they could sleep I feel bad for those
people you know what I mean I feel bad
for the American people that are looking
at the are suffering at the gas pump
suff suffering at the grocery stores and
constantly being told by the left that
you need to feel bad for someone else
somewhere more than you feel bad for
yourself I think it's time for Americans
to get a little bit more selfish in that
regard and stop and I I I I think they
will do I think we're we're suffering
enough now that people are going to yeah
you got to militarize the Border there
should be I mean this is I don't hear
this enough in the rhetoric but there
should be machine gun nests pointing
outward away from our borders saying and
but then what you need is a leader at
the top that's not waving people in
because if they're waving people in no
no Machine Gun Nest that's not we're not
going to do that but if I I think that
unless you tell them to stop coming and
I mean you do it with more than just
your words that it's not the problem
isn't going to I I I I appreciate what I
would describe as Ian's big ask and now
we're going to walk way back from
machine gun nests On the Border to like
maybe a fence it's it's not even that
you status authoritarian it's it's it's
more about not incentivizing this from
from happening I mean giving our
resource giving our tax dollars is is
essentially telling a lot of people
because I covered this situation on the
ground in Mexico I covered it in Europe
in in southern um Italy as well I I I
covered it all over the world and all
these people were told hey come on in
we're going to take care of you we're
going to give you all the opportunities
we're going to give you everything you
want but they don't tell them how
essentially a lot of multinational
corporations use them as slave labor
they don't tell them about a larger coch
brother plan that we used to have uh
members of the Senate to talk about
specifically from Vermont that no longer
bring it up as a key issue as of course
it is is affecting everyone it is
affecting the blue collar middle class
Americans and even more importantly the
poorest people in this country that are
now left out literally in the cold it is
a lie when they say that these are jobs
Americans don't want and we saw this
when Donald Trump I I think the number
was around 600 or so individuals
deported from meat processing plants in
the South and then once several hundred
people are are are deported these
companies say we need to hire so they
they have a job fair who shows up
Americans and there were interviews and
you can Google and watch these videos
one man is has asked why are you coming
to work at this plan you know these are
jobs that Americans don't want he goes
are you kidding pays 14 bucks an hour
that's more money than I'm making right
now it's a good job for me they they
want you to believe nobody wants these
jobs as they give them away and drop the
prices and I got to say it is these
large multinational corporations that
know they can pay people under the table
dirt wages and this is how they this how
this how they get cheap labor I I just
want to say one thing to to Ian's point
from
earlier I I think it's important to
understand what's going on like on the
ground in the southern border have have
any of you guys been to the southern I
should I have because actually you have
so I think that that probably affects
your view Candace it definitely affects
mine having been there it's not like you
have this situation where illegal
migrants or whatever are trying to cross
the Rio Grand sneak across get a Sprint
and then do you shoot them or not it's
not one of those
situations it's
organized by our own government it's
facilit it's actually what was striking
about it is there's a lot of things in
life that are pretty disorganized like
starting a startup company is pretty
disorganized you guys you guys maybe
have a SLE Enterprise here that you
started from a ground floor I've seen
you know a lot of things that are good
in life are disorganized this is not
disorganized this is striking because of
how markedly organized it actually is
there's a process they give you forms
here's the Box you check you don't have
to know English they'll just tell you
which box to check seeking Asylum do you
have to show proof of political
persecution to get Asylum not at all
it's just a procedure you go through you
know exactly go from point A to point B
to point C and so part of militarizing
the Southern border is the signal that
we send because that's the signal we're
sending right now not only coming in but
then you show up to Sanctuary City you
get you get baby formula you get
sneakers $77,000 per migrant per month
converting Southshore High School on the
south side of Chicago into an encampment
for migrants so I think part of what
we're doing is offering a clear
statement we end Federal funding for
Sanctuary cities you know in advance
that if you're child is born in the
United States they're not going to
actually enjoy citizenship oh there's a
there's a wall and a fence and people
wearing camo because they serve in the
US military facing outward I'll never
have the military carrying out domestic
law enforcement functions but facing
outward against what currently is an
organized Invasion into our country
that's I think what's going on and so
this idea of yeah guys with guns and do
you shoot or not it's just like just
it's just not even close to what's
happening right now and I think part of
this is goes back to it's not the
technicals that matter it's a statement
of intention if we believe and we have a
national ensus and I believe we
basically do but the Democratic party
needs to align and admit it openly that
we do not want large numbers of illegal
people entering this country we
absolutely and quickly can put an end to
it as a technical matter the problem is
there's a statement of intention that
not only is that not what the much of
the democratic party believes that same
Wing actually believes that is
inherently a good thing and the question
is how do you adopt policies that
facilitating it while pretending like
you actually wish for the opposite
that's really what this is about so all
the Technical Solutions become really
details footnotes compared to really a
debate about the intentions do you want
a mass change in the composition of the
US electorate and the composition of the
ethnic and and linguistic background of
people in the United States or don't you
that's what's on the table when it comes
to like uh using the law you said
earlier to you want to stick with the
law like focus on the law and really as
the president that is like your job as
the commander of the the military number
one but like Law and Order I get but
sometimes Law and Order can be used for
evil I agree and and we need to be
diligent or at least judicious about how
we Implement I don't know if you want to
call it prosecutorial or commandor uh
you
know expression you get to pick and
choose when you enforce when you enforce
the law so like deportations I I I'm
still my jury's out on this one right
now it was for me for a while too but I
think only I feel
nothing look look let let me let me
stress I people to turn on their
neighbors and be like I think he's
illegal and that kind yeah we're not
talking about that look there humans can
do bad things things I have I actually
have a tremendous amount of respect for
people who are willing to Traverse miles
through desert dozens or hundreds or
thousands of miles because the dream of
America is so incredible but it's got to
be a legal process but that's not even
the dream that's being sold to them
anymore it's just the IDE you're being
offered free stuff now you know I mean
this is not the American dream and I'm
suffering so much in this country and
I'm willing to Traverse through the
desert uh for an opportunity like you
said it is now systematic you are going
to have a better life as soon as you get
here it's all set up for you you know I
met a journalist that found the dumping
point where they're being told to dump
all of their IDs they're coming in on
flights from other countries dumping
their IDs because they're being told to
she had three bags filled with their IDs
and then they handed these pamphlets
from the UN by the way which was beyond
Bonker she showed me this pamphlet that
was coming from the UN and they're being
told to do this to come into this
country because they know that there are
politicians that are setting up an
entire system for them where their lives
will be better so this is not the same
the same mentality people that are
coming at the border right now we have
to let go of this idea that they're just
these suffering people who are willing
to do anything for an opportunity
they're just being offered handouts at
the expense of the americ assembly line
to bring them in free healthare and free
sex gender changes loty I'll use this to
segue one of the things I've heard uh
quite a bit many people back uh uh in my
hometown Chicago have said I can't
afford to pay the rent my groceries are
too expensive we just went to hi ve
grocery store out here it was great but
yo it was expensive I mean uh we we got
I got three things of salami I always
love buying salami and cheese dip a
couple things of heavy whipping cream
with our coffee four grocery bags it was
300 300 bucks to be fair we got some
vitamins and some protein powder I know
those a little bit more expensive but I
was surprised to see this little bit was
so much and I hear people say why are in
Chicago particularly when I went and
visited home they're giving these
they're paying these people rent they're
putting them in hotels they're giving
them our schools they're getting a free
pass from our tax dollars and I can't
afford to pay rent I can't afford to
survive so part of the the immigration
issue that many people are feeling is
the economic hit they're taking we're
paying taxes that are supporting all of
these these these flights where they're
bringing in hundreds or thousands these
buses they're being paid for yes by the
American taxpayer while the American
taxpayer suffers and can't afford to pay
rent yeah and I think actually that's
what makes this a nonpartisan issue this
should should be a slam dunk issue for
us so I this was your hometown Chicago I
didn't realize that I visited the south
side of Chicago earlier in this campaign
which is a very traditional campaign
Shore Southshore a couple of different
areas too but we went to South Shore
High School is where we finished the day
and oh really is where you grew up
Midway Airport oh two blocks away all
right well uh good deep dish pizza and
all that you know we we yeah called soup
there's some things to like well that's
the tourist stuff art of pizza check
yeah I mean I but that's what I am when
I go I mean we don't we don't get to go
to Chicago every day so we pick some on
the way out but you know it was
interesting where it was a room full you
know maybe like this one little bit
different ethnic composition was 95%
black 150% Democrat as they told me
before you went maybe that's how they
Count Their votes but but anyway it was
interesting right the first part of the
exchange was contentious because some
people came with some questions that
were I think there were some people who
had some real animous to me in that room
one woman she asked me a question walked
straight out because she didn't like my
answer on racial reparations but
actually things changed pretty quickly
when we got to the question of illegal
Mass migration where they're literally
converting the local high school into an
encampment for migrants at a cost of
$7,000 per migrant per month when the
people in that Community Americans are
asking the question what about me and
actually later it came up somebody else
asked me on their own I wasn't bringing
up bringing up foreign policy why are we
sending our money to Ukraine almost
challenging me like I was a person who
would presumably because being a
Republican or whatever believe that this
was a good idea and I explained that no
no no no this is actually a very bad
idea we should not be doing this and we
actually left with a lot of common
ground on both of those issues which is
why I think it's actually very important
not to see the America first movement
through the prism of even the Republican
party I mean the Republican Party means
very little it doesn't mean anything to
be a republican doesn't predict what you
mean based on on foreign policy doesn't
predict what you think about Free Speech
doesn't predict what you think about
National Security State overreach so
that label means a lot less but I think
that because of what you just said
people I mean it's expensive right now
people are struggling in this country
this is something that should cross
partisan lines racial lines I think
there's an opport for us to deliver a
landslide election in 2024 and a
landslide minus some Shenanigans is
still a win which you know I think is
something we have to prepare for and
that's kind of my wholeo in this thing I
saw several polls many of you may have
seen them uh the youth vote swinging
towards Donald Trump that's pretty
shocking but I have to imagine if uh uh
you know from where I grew up in Chicago
I've got my relatives talking about
they're they're talking about building
physical encampments taking a whole area
in the southide and building a camp from
scratch I remember when I was 16 I got
my first paycheck doesn't everybody
remember that and you're like I was
supposed to get paid you know eight
bucks an hour I worked x amount of hours
and then you look at your check and
you're like where's my money and then
all the older guys laugh and they were
like look at the tax section it's called
theft now imagine that's right now
imagine 16 17 18 year old kids working
their first first job or whatever get
that first paycheck they see how much
money is taken from them from their hard
labor they they they work their their
fingers to the Bone and then at the same
time on the news you your tax dollars
$77,000 per person per month we're
talking about
$84,000 a year for free to people who
are not from this country who have not
worked for this country and you
hardworking young men have a third of
your income taken by the government to
give to them and maybe it's because we
have a $34 trillion National Surplus to
spend on this I'm I'm just kidding it's
actually $34 trillion national debt
where we're already in the hole and so
anyway I do think that the silver lining
in this is that the more we kind of talk
about this through class IAL Republican
versus Democrat you know fire Biden kind
of mentality stuff which is super boring
and not the right way to look at this
election I think the more we're going to
fall into the Trap of getting another
50.1 election we're playing tug-of warar
and msnbc's trotten out the winner six
days after the ballots are
cast that's not the direction we need to
go I think there is a movement that
transcends partisan and racial
boundaries I think it translate it
transcends national boundaries right now
too in many ways what you see in certain
other countries but in this country I
didn't get 75 80% of this country
agreeing on many of the things we're
talking about right here hypothetical
you get elected day one what do you what
do you begin doing to help alleviate the
stress on the economy and the average
person to help them uh increase their
standard of living and better the
economy yeah look I think that there's
some very basic things to do one is the
easiest thing you could do to alleviate
both the national debt and the economy
at the same time there's a lot behind
this but I'll just get to the
punchline get the oil and natural gas
out from underneath our ground we know
how to do that sell it and buy down
about $8 trillion of our national debt
that takes us from 34 to 26 next end
this you know in a lot of the Foreign
Wars in Ukraine elsewhere that's another
7 trillion of our national debt now our
national debt problem 7 trillion was due
to Iraq and Afghanistan and I don't want
to be on the track to do the same thing
and then initiate a mass firing not a
chisel but a chainsaw style firing AA of
70 yeah 75% of federal bureaucrats start
that on day one that is of every four
people there three of the will be gone
definitely by the end of the ter first
term and preferably sooner and problem
is when you got a bunch of those people
showing up to work who should have never
had that job in the first place they
start finding new things to do a lot of
them is writing regulations that
Congress never authorized which is
acting like the wet blanket on the
economy and my first action as it
relates to the regulatory state is any
law that Congress didn't actually pass
or specifically instruct an agency to
write a regulation for it's my view and
the current Supreme Court's view that
it's unconstitutional resend all of them
and stay on day one we're stopping
enforcement of those regulations and
view them as null and void that grows
this economy it increases the supply of
housing think about housing we have land
use restrictions we have EPA
restrictions that are limiting new
housing construction increase the supply
brings down the cost grows the economy
energy unlock the supply of oil natural
gas coal nuclear energy increase the
supply bring down the cost grows the
economy stop paying people more money to
stay at home instead of a go to work
increase the supply of labor most small
businesses the hardest thing they find
right now to expand is to hire new
people to fill those roles so even
before I get to reform of the Federal
Reserve which is a favorite topic of
mine that's not a day one item just
literally day one these are the kind of
steps we can put into motion and yes I
think we get back to 4% GDP growth
possibly 5% GDP growth it could be even
mag we might land magnitudes of growth
because what we're going to do is
transform into a hydrogen based fuel
economy they figured out Rice University
how to he's not wrong yeah they take
that is interesting needed to hear that
but but he's not you know but I think
that uh they figured out how to make it
profitable to make hydrogen essentially
this has been the the entire time it's
like it cost too much money to make the
fuel they figured out you take plast you
take any carbon trash you hit it with a
laser called flash Jewel heating 7,000
Dees for .1 milliseconds and it turns it
into you can get hydrogen and graphine
as a byproduct which you can use as a
building material to build houses build
roads to to enforce your roads by them
three times stronger it's 200 times
stronger than steel by weight this
material pure carbon and for every
kilogram of hydrogen you produce with
this process you get about $4.50 of
graphine and then we can sell the
graphine you can also take the oil that
this would displace technically a
hydrogenic economy might displace the
oil you can turn the oil into graphine
so we can keep pumping it and we can
keep selling it now as esoteric as that
may be for many people the the core fans
of the show have heard it a million
times is right I think the the actual
simple message though is innovation and
the energ sector yes Beyond just oil it
could be hydrogen it could be Fusion I
mean there's big breakthrough there
nuclear energy you can pump the hydrogen
through the natural gas lines of the of
the planet so we've already got an
infrastructure the guy's name is James T
at Rice University I'll put you in touch
with if you want to go I would love to
learn more you going to say something no
I was just going to talk about nuclear
energy in terms of one of the main
obstacles to this and this I think to
the extent that this involves actually
what what exactly laser accomplishes but
is it sort of splitting the nuclear
electricity oh what do you I think that
it would it would it would not fall
within the RC's and the nuclear
Regulatory Commission no it's not
nuclear this process physical breakdown
just physical breakdown got it so so
I'll have to learn more about that but
I'm talking about at least the
production of more kinds of energy in
the United States including nuclear
energy again one of the obstacles is the
nuclear Regulatory Commission and again
the right answer is you can't reform
these agencies I think the right answer
is to get in there and just shut them
down one by one just say aa aa no
outside you're trying to say Fuego is
that what he was saying on the I mean
could like throw it out no when uh M
Wasing things off the wall yelling AA
you know I've said this many times if I
have not made Javier Malay look like a
moderate by the end of my first three
months I haven't done my job all right
so I like the guy I actually been
following for a long time goes around
with the chainsaw chainsaw first chisel
second yeah I think that's one of the
things that got me excited about you
just as a candidate was just it's
remarkable to me that we have all of
these people that are running and they
make it seem like being America First is
something that's dirty like it's
something that's wrong and I just could
not get over all of them paring this
point that we could do both right that
drove me crazy I wanted to scream as I
was yeah we can do both we can take care
of the ukrainians and every other
country we can do look around you that's
what I look around you does it look like
we are successfully doing both have we
been successfully doing both I mean this
country has been in a steep deine and a
large part of it is because what ends up
happening is what we saw on that stage
and what we've seen uh just throughout
this entire election process is just
people are bought and paid for right and
and the people that they tend to sell
out are always the American people we're
told that we have to feel bad we have to
put ourselves last it's always an
American last perspective y um and so
it's just been exciting to have you get
up there on the stage and everywhere
that you've been going and you've been
doing so many podcasts without question
I think everyone can agree that you have
been the hardest working candidate at
this election cycle I've seen you
everywhere I mean app obscure podcast
it's it's it's really wonderful just the
work ethic is so impressive um and young
and I'm a mother of three and so it was
something that was very important to me
and I'm just kind of shwing you with a
compliments here obviously but thank you
for that is something that's very scary
for me because when we talk about even
the process of illegal immigration you
think about that as a parent this is
also going to become issues down the
line when we talk about the violence
that is going to be imp parted in inner
cities this is something that terrifies
me something that terrifies me you have
unchecked people coming into this
country we know that they are coming
from countries where the cartels are
running things we have no idea who is
being brought into this country at this
moment as a parent that's terrifying yes
um and I just think a lot of the
candidates are not willing to talk about
these issues in a way um that is is
provides Clarity to those of us that are
worried about the future for our
children I think most I think most of
the candidates are really reading
scripts provided to them by their super
Pacs or the people who fund them I mean
I think that's effectively what American
politics has become for the worse and I
think you got to be willing to say I
mean it's sad the system works this way
but we've put our families put over 25
million close to $30 million into this
campaign there's going to be more going
in it's what it takes to run
presidential elections even still it's
hard to compete against the Super PAC
industrial complex where the amount of
money being spent on television
advertisements by the like of Nikki
Haley and Ronda sandz but it's not
really them it's the super Pacs that's
the real cancer on American politics and
the super Pacs culture selects for
candidates that just make them vessels
for advancing what that super pack
industrial complex wants to advance and
so one of the things I think again this
is an opportunity to go beyond
traditional partisan boundaries building
towards a Reagan 1980 style Landslide
you got Ukraine in that category you got
the southern Border in that category I
think we should be favoring ending
ending super packs not by violating any
First Amendment rights but by just
saying that you know what if there's a
$3,300 maximum that you can give to a
campaign that's what it is in the GOP
Primary that's a lot of money but it's
not enough to corrupt a politician who's
running for president
that if there's a Super PAC that's
donating to presidential candidates if
you're donating to that Super PAC you
should also be capped out at $3,300 per
prison I don't think that that's too
much to ask this used to be a leftwing
idea actually I think that right now
we're at a place where the Republican
Party absolutely can and should embrace
it I think it'll be widely popular and
again part of building
towards an 80 plus percent electoral
majority minus sh Shenanigans is still a
decisive Landslide Victory but anyway I
think that's what's going on is you kind
of have candidates when you start to
think that they're actually advancing
their own convictions we're kind of
missing the point their vessels for
advancing what the donors really want to
wield them to actually stand for there's
this issue in Iowa right now actually
which is super
interesting I was actually at an event
at the state capital earlier today say
like an esoteric issue maybe but it's
not really because it affects every
American is they're building a carbon
dioxide capture pipeline across this
state that we're in right now so they
make a lot of ethanol in the state they
say capture carbon dioxide build a
pipeline across the state and then bury
it in the ground in North Dakota why no
one really knows why other than the fact
that our federal government's providing
subsidies in the name of fighting
climate change because carbon dioxide is
a bad actor it doesn't make any sense I
carbon dioxide is plant food so this
idea of removing carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere being some sort of worthy
goal I could go on for a full day about
why that's based on a false premise it
but we're using our own taxpayer money
to pay people in the state there's a
business business couple of businesses
that are now using eminent domain to
seize the land of farmers here rights to
use their land when most Iowa farmers
who I've met do not like that being
built across their backyard so I could I
could go a little bit longer on this but
the point I'm bringing it up is not a
single other Republican candidate not a
single one has expressed opposition to
this carbon capture pipeline why because
the most powerful people at least in
this state as it relates to the
Republican donor establishment do not
permit you to oppose the carbon capture
pipeline interesting and so again it
comes back to that Mega Money In in
politics question could we go a little
bit deeper here because you you
mentioned the Federal Reserve just a
little bit and this is an institution
created in 1913 that's a quasi private
cartel parading around like it's some
kind of Private Bank when it's
essentially not Thomas Jefferson said
that he believes banking institutions
are more dangerous to our liberties than
standing armies with their corporate
bailouts with the inflation which is
essentially a tax on the poor a theft of
resources from the poorest people in
this country and the FED yes or no I
would like to but that requires
legislation I make promises that I will
keep as your next president and here's
the promise I'll keep with respect to
the FED is a 90% headcount reduction at
the usfed combined with restoring
effectively a single mandate one purpose
Peg the dollar to Commodities stabilize
the dollar as a unit of measurement it
should be just a basic function of
arithmetic and nothing more and again
part of the problem is you got those not
23,000 people or so at the US Federal
Reserve now that we don't need to do
that narrow function of pegging the
dollar to Commodities they find things
to do that's where the Central Bank
digital currency comes from that's where
a lot of these the cbdc which is a back
door way of ensuring a government
surveillance system of being able to
wipe you out for doing something the
government didn't approve of that's how
you get to raining money from on high
like Mana from heaven in the aim of
balancing inflation and unemployment
it's like the equivalent of hitting two
Targets with one arrow and missing at
both so hopefully that answers so we'll
we'll dive a little bit into that
because one of the big stories today is
that the SEC has approved Bitcoin ETFs I
believe more than just I think it's
crypto Market ETFs and there's a lot of
people who are concerned about a lot of
people cheering it on but this brings us
to uh the acceptance of the US
government as it pertains to crypto and
the fear that they're going to push
Central Bank digital currency also known
as cbdc could you explain to people what
that is and your position on cbdc sure
and and so let's just take
decentralized DEC ized options in the
blockchain like block like Bitcoin or
otherwise put that to one side I think
greater decentralization at least has an
option that's available to hold the
dollar to its feet as an alternative to
opt out from that system is a good thing
let me pause you real quick though sorry
just there's probably a lot of people
who don't know what Central Bank digital
currency even so let me just let's just
so I was going to I was going to
segregate the issue of Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency away from the Central
Bank digital currency which the easiest
way to think about this would be turning
your dollar into a effectively a digital
asset that's centrally monitorable we
could use you know talk about which way
they would use the blockchain or not it
doesn't matter the simple way to think
about it is take the cash in your pocket
and convert that into the equivalent of
like tokens you'd get in a digital video
game and they can either up or down the
number of points you have which are
dollars in your bank account not based
on how what you deposit or take in or
take out but based on whatever the
government actually decides is the
criteria for increasing or decreasing
what's in your bank account indeed
they're doing this in China in fact
that's one of the principal Arguments
for bringing it to the United States is
that China is adopting a digital Yuan
has a equivalent of a central bank
digital currency in China now we have to
ask ourselves why is China doing it the
general argument in the UK which is
moving in this direction and the US
which is taking the earliest of steps to
move in this direction through the
so-called fed now program the argument
is we have to keep up technologically
with China keep up with the Joneses or
keep up with the Xin pings as the case
may be here right you to ask yourself
why is China doing it they want to
actually be able to exert monitoring and
control and discipline of their own
citizens it's the ultimate manifestation
of a social credit system so that's what
this is about in China now there's a
version of this it wasn't exactly
through a central bank digital currency
per se but to at least understand the
impact it could have on your life look
at what they did to the Canadian
truckers they cut off access to their
bank accounts they cut off access to
their Canadian dollars when they took a
position against vaccine mandates and a
position against lockdowns that they
couldn't address through any means other
than through using the weaponization of
the financial system to do it so if we
bring that Central Bank digital currency
to the United States it offers another
tool for what would be otherwise a
tyrannical permanent government to be
able to more effectively Implement its
will to be clear and some people fall
into this trap of thinking that just
because we eliminate the tool we've
eliminated the intention no the
intention still exists but that doesn't
mean that you still give them the same
tool that would allow them to more
quickly Implement what they already are
looking to in other ways I'd like to uh
elaborate on why this would be so
nightmarish several year uh I mean we're
talking eight or so years ago 10 years
ago we started seeing the rise of social
media censorship if you tweeted
something that was against the popular
narrative you get you'd get suspended
many of us were called conspiracy
theorists for arguing what was actually
happening in fact it was reported by I
believe it was Gizmodo 1 in May of 2016
that Facebook had staff removing
conservative news outlets from their
trending tab that's just your ability to
speak I know one of the more serious
things to be able to lose to not be able
to engage in the public sphere imagine
the same scale of censorship but in
terms of you buying milk bread and eggs
yes one day you wake up and you go to
the grocery store and you're using your
app because that's what the Central Bank
digital currency will be forced to be on
your phone and you'll walk up you'll put
your milk on the self checkout because
there's no humans anymore you'll scan
your phone and it'll say you have been
banned from purchasing for 24 hours due
to hate speech or docked a certain
number of dollars by the way just going
back to just bringing up Co and the
things that we saw throughout Co that
was one of my major concerns that I
spoke about uh just the digitization of
everything that was happening at that
time suddenly like they were trying to
say your menus could have potentially
have covid they kept saying that dollar
bills this was do you remember this in
the news dollar bills could spread Co
and suddenly they didn't want any more
dollar bills we're no longer accepting
cash was so many restaurants uh grocery
stores no long St cash because you could
potentially spread covid which was an
absurdity in my mind an absolute
absurdity but a lot of these things are
now long lasting right in in terms of
the fact that there's not that many
human beings I don't know if that's the
same where you live but not that many
human beings at the grocery store
anymore they kept up the things after
covid that they said were just for covid
and I felt that it was very much because
they did want us to move in this
direction as Society well you can see in
Las Vegas potentially to prep us for
this and I just want to play that one
step forward to tie earlier to one of uh
an increasingly what looks like a
republican policy of certainly of a
certain candidate of tying your
government issued ID to your internet
account or your social media account so
now combine that with the Central Bank
digital currency now you don't have to
tie just milk in the grocery store every
time you hit like on a tweet that does
not match the regime's approved
narrative we could dock you 50 cents
iFit retweet you actually dock you
dollar and so Jack Smith I just want to
tie this together right right now in the
subpoena for one of the federal cases
against Donald Trump there's so many of
them you lose track but it's one of the
Jackson Smith Federal
prosecutions in that subpoena I think
it's what people understanding it
certainly affects people who are
watching us right now might affect some
of us in this room maybe some of us at
this table I don't know not me because I
wasn't using Twitter back then but if
you retweeted or liked one of Donald
Trump's posts in that
year that's now the subject of Jack
Smith's subpoena so let's play that
forward that that your your username or
whatever has already been the subject of
that subpoena now say that that handle
was tied to your government issued ID
which is also tied to your digital
dollar he can't convict you in court
necessarily but why don't we give him a
nice little spanking take a few dollars
out of their bank account that's
literally where this vision of the the
so-called great reset that's where this
land that would be a coup that would be
something that would be an attempted
coup by global enforcement Powers uh
that we cannot allow to happen they can
already freeze your bank accounts when
you're under investigation say you
worked for a company and then all of a
sudden one day you can't buy things but
with the Central Bank digital currency
it goes so far beyond that we're going
social credit system but it's automated
it's to where it won't even be a judge
saying I think there's probable cause to
freeze his account it's going to be a
machine saying your account is frozen
and good luck imagine having to go to
the DMV every time you needed to get
your bank unbanned and this is the I
tell me if this is like too abstract and
we can sort of bring it back but it's a
pattern that repeats itself in so many
different places where right now you're
right they can freeze your bank account
even as it exists today but it takes
something that requires the government
to take a Quantum step right you have to
have a preponderance of evidence that's
50.1 to con percent chance of actually
having done it and then to actually
convict somebody you have to be Beyond a
reasonable doubt that's 99.999% 100%
certainty so you have to take these
Quantum steps of certainty what the
Central Bank digital currency does is it
takes this system that ties a Quantum
level certainty and just makes it
continuously varying right so it's not
like Jack Smith is going to say that
he's going to wipe out your entire bank
account and freeze your entire bank
account the way this would work is I'm
just going to dock You by 50 Cents like
I think that's actually the thing to see
is it wouldn't be if we were using the
analogy Tim I think it would be less
that we're not going to allow you to buy
the milk at all it's going to be that
instead of having $100 you now have 99
so it's designed to change behaviors at
the margin and that's really where this
is different from the current stat
status quo where they technically could
also freeze your bank account entirely
couldn't buy any milk it's not that it's
that you like to post we didn't quite
like we see that because of your
government issued ID tied to your social
media profile it's not like we need to
go to the court system for that it's not
like you've done something criminal but
we're just going to dock you a little
bit with a little so-called nudge in the
right direction that's actually what's
actually far more frightening with the
cbdc there's so much more here too we we
can't even begin to imagine how about
geol loocking transactions meaning let's
say is a a political rally happening in
DC and the President says we're going to
have a rally so then anybody who attends
that rally their F their their their
ability to transact is shut off within
50 miles and just these individuals all
of a sudden you can't buy train tickets
you can't buy milk you can't buy pizza
you can't go to the you can't go to
McDonald's to buy food and for anybody
who thinks that's a ridiculous example I
I believe it's Bank of America that
handed over records for anybody who was
in Washington DC on January 6 2021 to
Jack Smith which is exactly not that far
from what you're describing today so but
I think it's worth I think for the
people there's a lot of people in New
Hampshire that fit this category when
I'm campaigning there who come up and
ask like this will be the first question
they ask at a town hall it's like tell
me about your position on
cbdc I I share why I think it's a risk
but I think it's important not to fall
in the Trap of thinking just because
we've stopped that you still have a
government that can do a lot of these
things to you it's just that it becomes
a lot easier for the government to do
these things to you when they can do it
in small increments rather than Bank of
America having to hand it over to a
prosecutor he needed to go through
probable cause a lot of this can just be
done much more easily so even as we put
the kabash on the cbdc and I will and
that's easy it's just simple executive
action this is never going to happen in
the United States I'll get that done in
January of 2025 a year from now we're
good it's still just you know it's like
a water balloon it's like a hydraulic
pump system you squeeze it here it's
it's going to show up somewhere else and
so we're always kind of one step behind
and the reason people don't pay
attention ESG cbdc whatever is the more
you acronym eyesee it the more boring
you make it
the less likely you are to the people
are to pay attention to it and I think
that's why they te we have time for one
more segment before we go to questions
so I want to bring up uh this issue this
is from reuters.com Ohio House of
Representatives overrides video V veto
of Bill Banning gender affirming care so
one of the one of the big cultural
issues of course is the issue around
transgender youth uh uh transgender
ideology gender ideologies that pertains
to sports and of course one of the
truths that you have listed is that
there are two genders so
many of us were shocked to see that in
Ohio despite the fact that the house
passed this bill saying no to child sex
changes the governor tried to veto that
I'm curious your position on this if
you'd like to elaborate and break it
down yeah I and it happens to be my home
state actually born and raised and live
in Ohio now as well so I was
disappointed but not shocked as how I
would characterize it based on the
governor that we now have in Ohio
actually spoke to the lieutenant
governor I was sort of like what the
heck call who actually have a good
relationship with and turned out that he
is also against the position the
governor took and so the governor of
Ohio is is you know he's like the
equivalent of like the Chris sonunu the
Nikki Haley the you know Chris Christies
you could say of the world dwine the
governor of a just falls into that
category I mean there's a there's a
brand of people who put a nice little r
after their name but aren't really
thinking according to clear principles
they're easily captured I think in this
case what my understanding was and I
haven't talked to the governor but I've
talked a lot of people who are familiar
with the situation is a lot of people
are making good money off of some of
this gender conversion stuff and sold a
myth that somehow this is going to cause
suicides amongst kids and you're going
to have blood on your hands and so what
ended up happening was they just got him
to veto it well I'll I'll answer I I do
want to get into your prision but I want
to address what you just said about the
the the myth of the suicide and I'll use
I'll use the numbers that are widely
accepted there's something referred to
as desistance are you're familiar with
this concept not really desistance is
not detransition transition is if
someone identifies his trans underes
what they like to call gender affirming
care and then backtracks detransitioning
desistance is when a child says that
they're trans and and experiences
symptoms of gender dysphoria but without
any transition eventually grows out of
it typically this happens around puberty
the accepted rates are between 65 and
95% of young of young children who
experience gender dysphoria will grow
out of it and they call this
desistence that means if we give the
most uh benefit of the doubt we could to
the gender ideology argument 65 around
65% of of children will desist okay
their argument however is it's
life-saving to transition these children
but suicide rates could be as high as
48% this means that you are increasing
the likelihood of suicide by by
transitioning a child if the if there is
a two to one chance the child will
desist do not transition them and then
give them a 50% chance suicide well yes
it is a fact that suicide rates go up
after they transition I covered this
extensively on my podcast I've had D
transitioners on my podcast people that
have gone through with the procedure uh
you know got the bottom surgery as they
call it and then woke up one day and
realized their entire lives were AE and
to hear those stories I mean it's
incredible it's it's a true evil and it
is being backed by big Pharma uh there
is a lot of money obviously with these
procedures the drugs the puberty
blockers out there putting them on Loop
Ron um and it's a part of a larger
problem something that I'm obviously
very passionate about and in terms of
people not being educated and being sold
lies and then going through a very
radical route of via big Pharma to to
earn money I I don't know how far you
want to go with this because um I I see
a link to transhumanism I see a link to
Eugenics I see the rise of autism also
linked to a lot of this as well there's
a lot of different components that we
should really talk about I and I think
more importantly especially when it
comes to the kind of chemical biological
war against human beings when you look
at uh male hormones and and women's
hormones they're being disregulated they
are being directly attacked fertility is
being directly attacked by a lot of
forces outside of us how can we address
a larger what I see clearly a
depopulation agenda that has clearly
been put in play and being used against
us right right now to wrap it all
together I suppose as president what
could you do to address these issues
around gender ideology and even a
decline INF fertility oh so those are I
I think there's a couple couple
different issues I mean gender ideology
a lot of this is being fored through the
Department of Education right so the
Department of Education actually uses
the federal money as a news to get local
schools to adopt ideologies that the
Department of Education decides are the
acceptable ones keep in mind the origin
of the Department of Education people
sometimes forget was to prevent Southern
schools in Southern States from
siphoning money away from predominantly
black school districts to white ones but
it's come somehow that institution has
taken on its purpose to voice these
radical gender and some cases racial
ideologies also onto local schools so as
it relates to the schools and the
ideology piece of it a lot of this is
the head of the snake the Department of
Education a lot of it violates existing
civil rights laws and otherwise so
enforcing the laws in the books combined
with actually shutting down the
Department of Education is a pretty good
start now as it relates to what I see as
an appropriate place for a federal you
can talk about what how Reagan did it
using you could talk about technically
using how do we get set the drinking age
at 21 it was a 1984 law that effectively
says you don't get Highway funds unless
you adopt this particular set of laws
that at the drinking age of 21 but
forgetting about the legal mechanics and
just as a matter of policy what we want
in this
country if you're not 18 years old you
should not be getting any chemical
castration or genital mutilation just as
you can't get a tattoo just as you can't
have ad an addictive drink of alcohol
and so my view is we do live in a free
country if you're an adult a fully grown
adult you're free to dress how you want
you're free how to identify how you want
as as long as you're not harming anybody
else don't expect us to change the way
we compete in women's sports don't
expect to change the way we label our
bathrooms to change our language but if
you want to live your life the way you
want as long as you're not hurting
somebody else with a presumptive
expectation that the rest of society
bends to your delusion you're free to do
so but kids aren't the same as adults
and so I think protecting children is a
policy position we've already well
accepted in this country and so the same
logic and the same mechanism we use to
prevent you from drinking by the age of
21 that we prevent you from getting a
tattoo by the age of 18 you should not
be undergoing genital mutilation or
chemical castration as a minor in this
country and I think there's a pretty
broad consensus around that and I want
to add to this I think it's interesting
because when it comes to the issue of
drinking you can have a drink at the age
of 21 and be fine you can have a drink
at the age of 31 and be fine alcoholism
that's bad but if at the age of 21 you
decide to undergo permanent and
irreversible surgery and that was a
mistake you can't come back from that
that's right so this is this is there is
a serious challenge in how we how we
deal with an issue like this because I
don't want people to take take their
lives I think that's horrifying but we
did have a guest on this show who said
that she thought she was a man she
believed the gender ideology she was
being uh fed on the internet and she
talked to I think she said she talked to
her brother and he said get your
hormones checked first you likely have a
hormone imbalance so instead of adopting
the gender ideology and taking
testosterone when she went to the doctor
and got her hormones checked it turned
out turns out that she did have a
hormone imbalance so they prescribed her
female hormones she said almost
instantly gender dysphoria disappeared
and she was in alignment with her her
own body yeah and so my concern is if
someone like that were to undergo a
surgery and then regret it later I'm not
going to pretend to know what the a
doctor say one word about this I don't
know this person or this individual but
there is a really small number of so I
say there are two genders and that's a
clear clear point there is a small
number of people in the general
population who have chromosomal
abnormality ities so we have you know
what 23 pairs of
chromosomes two of them are sex
chromosomes x one is X and Y if you're a
man x and x if you're a woman but there
are some people who are born with XY y
or xxy and that's like a real thing
that's grounded in truth it's not made
up it's it's in your genetics one is
called kleinfelter syndrome one is
called Jacob syndrome these are
exceedingly rare we're talking about one
in thousands at a much lower rate so in
those particular cases yes those are
instances of what you will call interex
which is a different phenomenon than
trans but what's happened is let's take
those rare cases to one side and I don't
know if this person you had here had
such a thing or not I would have said
not not just go check your hormones go
actually get a genetic test and actually
understand are you one of the rare
people with one of these chromosomal
abnormalities it's
inborn but for the purpose of this
discussion in in our modern politics I
don't think that this pertains to public
policy take that off the table that
exists and we're going to acknowledge
that that's like a tiny tiny tiny
percentage of the population it's always
exist it's a chromosomal abnormality for
the rest of people transgenderism the
belief that you are your gender does not
match your biological sex that if you're
XX but you believe you're a man it is a
mental health disorder and it needs to
be treated as a mental health disorder
through mental health care which often
isn't covered by Private health
insurance a lot of this is through
pharmaceutical intervention they prefer
pill pushing behaviors as an alternative
or people who run surgery centers prefer
Sur surgery pedling surgery as an
alternative this is a mental health
condition and once we see it that way we
realize the compassionate thing to do
just from a standpoint because I think
we've gotten put into this box of see
being somehow antipathic because of
adopting this set of views that I think
some seems like most of us
share I don't think the compassionate
thing to do for that kid is to affirm
that kid's confusion that's not
compassion that is cruelty and I think
we should actually feel that shouldn't
be just a thing we say we should
acknowledge that and act with the
compassion to say that kid's going
through a struggle help the kid get
through the struggle
that's what we should be doing not
surgically operating on them and
chemically castrating them you you
pointed out that it is a mental health
disorder it is listed in the dsm5 as a
mental health disorder this is an
academic statement this is not meant to
be invective yeah but there are many
people that I speak with who are liberal
or democrat that get offended when I
point out the fact that it is listed in
the dsm5 as a me mental health disorder
and my argument is uh there's another
mental health disorder called Pica are
you familiar with this no it's where
people eat things that aren't food we
don't affirm these things we try to help
these people because I agree with you as
you said to tell someone eating pennies
is something they should do is is
cruelty to them see I think that one of
the things I would say talking to
someone on the left on this who finds
that
offensive is isn't that really
stigmatizing mental health disorder to
say that you consider it so offensive to
have a mental health disorder that that
should trigger the fact that you have a
mental health condition to say that
that's in such a category
that it is so offensive that you said
such a thing about me I think the
compassionate thing to do is actually
recognize that there are many Americans
who go through a lot especially now more
than even 30 40 years ago social media
and otherwise playing the loss of
purpose the loss of faith we can go
deeper on that yes there are all kinds
of mental health conditions that are
rampant in the United States of America
today we should have empathy towards
people who suffer from those mental
health conditions figure out how we're
going to address that bring back
psychiatric institutions bring back
mental health institutions address the
violent wave of violent crime across
this country but we're not able talk
about that because now what you've
actually done is abandon your
leftwing crony quasi compassionate
instinct or supposedly compassionate
instincts to actually just say we're
demonizing you because you have a mental
health condition as opposed to saying
that's the truth of what's Happening
Here that's what I that's what I find
odd about that left reac explosion of
transgenderism though what we've seen
over you know the last 10 years I would
say is definitely these people are not
being born with a mental disorder what's
happening is they are being given a
mental disorder almost like mun yeah
this is like a Munch hous in proxy
societal munchow and bioxy where you
have teachers are conditioning them you
have parents on the internet that want
to be seen as accepting and they're
training their children they're
confusing their children it's actually
systematic abuse that's and the way you
know that's true Candace is actually you
look at in covid-19 they would talk
about this this coefficient r squared
whatever fancy way of saying how how
fast a virus spreads from person to
person the r squared rate for
transgender exactly and a given school
where a kid starts to identify as a
gender different than their biological
sex is arguably far greater than it was
for covid-19 0% in my high school and
now it's it's it was like it's not
linear it's like a it's like an
exponential curve so uh usually around
this time we would go to our super chats
I will go through these we'll grab a few
good questions but uh as we're setting
up the event of course the uh the events
team over at timcast was like we're
going to ask people to submit questions
and then we'll get them to ask the
questions and I said I don't think V
wants to do that I think we should just
grab random people let them ask their
questions and yeah I don't like
prescreening yeah I said I I I I think
we should just have real questions
whatever they may be and I'm pretty sure
we can handle it so we're going to go
I'm not ready for xiin Ping if I can't
handle some audience question hey but
look it's it's fascinating every every
other political campaign is give us the
questions beforehand because we don't
want to look bad on TV so we're just
going to go for it I I think uh Phil
Phil leonty of All That Remains is here
he's going to be helping uh hello hey
there we go how you doing everybody very
L uh it's Phil's discretion I guess
right so what we're going to do is uh
young Andrew here is going to grab you
if you put your hands up we're GNA have
one person waiting here one person's
going to come up here and ask the
question when this person gets done you
can go ahead and move on and we'll move
on like that everyone okay with that I'm
okay with it everyone okay with that yes
thank you very much uh Andrew go
ahead what's your name
Drew uh this question is for Viv uh but
Candace feel free to add in since you've
done a lot of Journalism on the topic I
speak not only for myself but for
countless others uh without a voice and
parents that that had to bury their
children too
early how will you achieve T tangible
accountability for those permanently
damaged by the covid-19 vaccines when
will it happen and why is it important
to you army Sergeant retired Drew thank
you drew thank you for your service to
this
country thank you drew I I'll say a
couple of things and you're right
Candace has been ahead of the curve on
this issue for the last several years
but I'll tell you what we can do you
can't change the past but you can at
least make sure that where there has
been injury there must be Justice and I
think as far as I know I'm the only
presidential candidate to pledge to do
this I will require Congress for this
one I try to be clear but it will
require Congress I will repeal the
special liability exemptions that
pharmaceutical companies enjoy in this
country it is dead wrong and it is
unjust normally any product
that's sold to you if it harms you you
can sue the manufacturer except for
vaccine manufacturers why crony
capitalism pharmaceutical industry
lobbying it's disgusting and actually I
love Reagan as a president for a lot of
things that he did he was wrong on this
one and actually closing the psychiatric
hospitals was the same thing Reagan was
actually pretty good at getting lobbied
by the pharmaceutical industry people
will get mad for me saying that it's
just a fact doesn't take away from his
other accomplishments so that's number
one number two relates specifically this
one doesn't require Congress I'm going
to do it in my capacity as commander in
Chief for our US military especially for
you as somebody who served that's why
I'm adding this extra element to this
anybody who lost their job in the US
military for making what for many of
those young men is obviously the right
choice young men and women
alike is that you will have your
position restored with full back pay
times one and a half that's something
I'm committed to do as the next
president of the United States as well
and make sure something like this never
happens again so those are two examples
of Tang things I'll be able to deliver
you and I'd like to give the obligatory
for our friends over at YouTube make
sure you talk to a trusted medical
health professional and not podcasters
about how to take care of your health
needs great but but thank you so much
for your question there's so many people
that have been injured and hurt here and
they don't have a voice so thank you for
being that voice did you have a followup
Candace yeah no I just wanted to add on
to it uh just to make sure that people
understand this is the issue I'm the
most passionate about I have an entire
show called a shot in the dark to
educate people it was not the covid-19
vaccine first it's all of the vaccines
and are not aware of what the
ingredients are are not aware that the
FDA insert I created the show I do not
use weird sources it's the CDC website
and the FDA inserts that warn you of
what can happen if you take these
vaccines um it's important for people to
understand the history of the illnesses
that you think you're fearful of that
you have no idea uh Ms measles rubella
people don't know anything about these
diseases and yet think that big Pharma
and cleaned these things up it's a deep
di that I've done it's the most
important work that I do um and to know
that these injuries people getting sick
the seizures the autoimmune diseases
that we're seeing today um it is all
related to the vaccines that they're
giving children and it is directly
related to the lobbying we've got more
big Pharma lobbyists than we do have
Congress members in DC and that is
entirely problematic but um if you are a
parent or if you are just a person that
is not educated about vaccines I I
created an entire series on it called a
shot in the dark and as I said we only
use above the board because I am not a
doctor you should not listen to me I am
just a mother of three children I don't
VX any of my children as people know um
but it's get educated you know be being
inform forign before you before you jump
into getting vaccines you should
understand what the risks are yeah Bill
G definitely knows what's right and I
want to stress this point too because a
lot of people have also responded to us
when we've said you know find a medical
professional you trust hey if you go to
a doctor and they're a bad doctor and
they're not giving you good advice you
got a bad doctor same is true for any
plumber or Carpenter there there are
good doctors out there that can that can
tell you what you need to know and I
recommend you find them it's very
empowering to question your doctor the
first time you do it you realize they're
just people and they'll answer your
question second opinions are a normal
thing I don't trust fat doctors but
that's just me anyway shall we hey can I
can I actually ask I got two people here
I was going to bring up earlier I forgot
is if if you guys are we can pull up a
chair actually got Jeff Shipley and
Steve Holt two state legislators here in
Iowa who actually endorsed me in the
last 24 hours and actually one of them I
want to bring them these are good A lot
of these are state level questions too
smart guys strong constitutional and
Steve Hol in particular was a I hope
Steve doesn't mind me saying this was a
strong Ronda santis dis did the uh
endorser and came over uh today as well
so I'm Glad You Came guys came to the
join us up here Eddie you're here too I
didn't know you were here wow three
strong constitutionals bring it bring
them up here we can just spread them out
spread them out around here have some
lawmakers especially got Ians asking the
questions these are the people they've
they've elected and do we have any other
question glad to have their
support Phil yep good to see you guys
yeah you can lend them your mic if they
wanted to say anything or yeah
absolutely same same as mine and then we
could grab more questions as well
welcome to the freaking show should
should these gentlemen introduce
themselves yeah absolutely do you guys
want to Let's uh yeah Eddie's right by
you you want to start with Eddie oh here
we go Eddie hey Eddie Eddie was the
first one to endorse me I appreciate
that
Lon we got you on the camera right here
hey hey what's up Iowa that's all I got
to
say I think technically I have known VI
longer than anybody here uh I follow
this guy
I saw him on CNBC and something told me
you know how we used to say back when we
were kids something told me to follow
this dude I liked what you said it
wasn't about politics and ever since
then I've been following you uh long
since you you w Kink book tour I think
was yes and you signed that woke Inc
book to my favorite Iowa legislator
thank you very much that's all I got to
say this the first one I met but it was
also my favorite and I've loved you ever
seen good when when VI announced
I want to say March Fe February yeah um
he had a
0.1% name
recognition not
approval like nobody knew who this guy
was and I said you know what if you drop
this guy in Iowa his message is going to
resonate and you have to hear him like
four or five times because everyone else
was well known but I just knew that this
message would begin to resonate so thank
you man I appreciate the appreciate the
support good guys oh yeah Eddie Andrews
I represent Johnston
Urbandale
sailor and a little bit of Southwest sty
right here loc in po County good man
good man Steve Holton you want to say a
quick hello before we take more
questions probably sure good yeah so
good evening everyone I'm Steve hold I
spent 20 years in the United States
Marine Corps I've been in the Iowa House
of Representatives I'll start my 10th
year if you Google me you'll find out
I'm the guy that ran the bill that
banned gender transition surgeries and
andother Iowa uh there we go I am also
the guy that ran constitutional carry in
Iowa you'll find I kind of do those
things um I had I had earlier uh
endorsed Governor Dan santis early on I
didn't know a lot about viik and my
decision my decision today to to uh
endorse uh V wasn't anything about
Governor DeSantis but rather his message
has resonated with me we are having an
identity crisis in this country because
of the Relentless attacks on our
national identity by the left and by the
mainstream media this is a 1776 moment
and as a United States Marine who fought
for this country for 20 years I'm not
going to miss that moment and I'm proud
to be supporting God bless here we
go we got a strong liberty-minded
Patriot here
too uh greetings well hello uh at first
just want to thank God and thank you
guys it's an honor to be with so many
amazing Americans here on this panel and
in this room really is a great privilege
my name is Jeff Shipley I serve Iowa
house district 87 I'm in my my sixth
year as a legislature and it's just very
exciting to be a part of the caucus
process and influence the national
debate here thank you man thank you yeah
sure Candace if I don't get a picture
with you my wife's going to kill me I
will let you get a picture with me two
pictures thank you shall we grab some
more questions yeah let's do
it what's your name I'm actually I go by
Eve apologist on the Discord hi everyone
glad to be out here good to see you
again thank you on number three now but
hello uh I know you see a lot of people
so I'm probably just yeah but I'm here
good to see you thanks okay so tough
question for you today we're going to
talk religion okay uh V considering your
experience attending Christian schooling
while not identifying as Christian could
you elaborate on how that experience
aligned with your family's religious
beliefs and if you faced any judgments
or challenges from the institution or
your peers U my concern is that as I
prepare to get married and hopefully
become a mother that our family may
experience difficulties and even
impostor syndrome as we venture into
exploring private and homeschooling
options and the same is true of the
overarching focus on what are called
judeo-christian values time and time
again and have me as a TR traditionalist
wondering when the other shoe will drop
for me and my loved ones who are not
religious yet share the same values from
a secular Viewpoint I know that your
first truth is God that God is real and
although I respectfully disagree with
that solitary point I would earnestly
like to know if you think it's possible
for families with a focus in secular
humanism to have a similarly positive
experience in religious education or a
place in your movement where one of the
tenets of unifying principles stands in
direct odds with our religious freedoms
so it's a great question I I uh first of
all think
that the job of the US president is to
swear an oath to the Constitution and to
keep it that includes the First
Amendment which includes religious
liberty the freedom of relig religious
exercise which includes the right not to
practice a particular Faith either and
so that's squarely the job of the US
president and I think that that was a
that was there was a lot of
thoughtfulness in that question because
yes I was the Lone Hindu student in a
Catholic High School in Cincinnati Ohio
and I did take a a lot away from that
religious education despite not
converting to Catholicism at the end of
it and so my core belief system is that
there's one true God God put put us here
for a purpose it's our moral duty to
realize that purpose that we're all
equal God works through Us in different
ways but we're all equal because God
still resides in each of us that's the
heart of my faith my Hindu faith I think
there's deep compatibility with the
values it's a different faith and a
different theology but the value system
including the judeo-christian values
that this country was founded on now
what are the Ten Commandments say I read
them for the first time in ninth grade
there's one true God don't take his name
in vain observe the sabbath honor your
parents don't kill don't lie don't cheat
don't steal don't commit adultery don't
covet broadly in simpler terms that's
what brought broadly they
say if I as a Hindu can certainly find
common purpose with those shared values
and I do and I think those are
judeo-christian values I think this
nation was as a historical fact found on
judeo-christian values then I believe
somebody who has a contion worldview or
pick your favorite secular
ordering can also find common cause with
those values I believe it's easier to
arrive at those values just mentally if
you anchor yourself grounded than God I
think it's actually a lot harder to get
there through secular World Views if you
want to follow you know Emmanuel Kant or
whoever else I think it's a harder path
But to answer your question can somebody
who is secular non-r religious agnostic
or atheist still find common cause with
the shared value set that this country
was founded on
absolutely and even more even if you
disagree with some of those values do
you have the right to live in this
country and are you still protected by
the same constitutional rights the
answer to that is also absolutely yes in
the United States of America and that's
what it means not to run for pastor and
I would be certainly an odd choice to
run for
pastor of a Christian
church but that's not the job of the US
president the job of the US president is
to swear an oath to the Constitution and
to keep it mean far as I know one of our
conversations Steve is um a Christian
Eddie's a Eddie were you're a pastor
your
minister and and I think that we're not
here out of our role to join the
ministry together but out of our shared
commitment to the Constitution and so
the answer to your question is yes and I
am sharing with you always what my true
convictions are we are one nation under
God it's part of our Creed I think part
of what's happened in this country is
we've turned God into a four-letter word
which I don't think should actually is
good is good for our culture I don't
think it's good for kids I don't think
it's good for National Unity but that
doesn't mean that if you're an atheist
somehow you're not welcome in this
country I think that as long as you
share the shared commitments to the
Constitution you're still an American
and that's what matters so thank you I
appreciate
that
how you doing what's your name summer
summer yeah I'm nervous I might Yak
that's okay okay on January 4th a
deranged individual named Dylan Butler
went to the Perry High School he killed
11-year-old Amir he wounded seven others
including four students three staffers
before killing
himself I'm genuinely
terrified can we mandate the presence of
arms staff members in public and private
schools schools contain America's most
valuable resources and should not be
soft
targets there are many teachers janitors
counselors and school administrators
that would be more than willing to
receive training and obtain a conceal
and carry permit to protect our children
I want at least one armed staff member
in the building before the school's
doors open in the
morning I mean it's really it's really
um I mean it's really tragedy what
happened here in Perry Iowa and I think
the worst tragedy of all was the fact
that the reaction to it was I just
certainly from a national perspective
was almost numb actually wasn't a
national story it was a story here in
Iowa I happened to be in Perry the
morning when it happened we saw a bunch
of ambulances helicopters you knew
something was going on the question was
we're going to cancel our event we
canceled the political event but we kept
the event intact as a prayer session and
and an open discussion for people in the
community and it was was amazing the
number of people who came who otherwise
wouldn't have just because they wanted
to speak
openly the short answer to your question
is I don't think one is sufficient just
that's just a logistical point I think
we need a minimum of three armed
security guards in every school across
this country some schools that are
really large might be benefit from four
or five states that lack the funding to
do it have a great place to start shut
down the Department of Education return
the money back to States and for a tiny
fraction of that you could have three to
four in every school across this country
Steve you going to mention something oh
Jeff yeah I just want to tell you that
there's a school district in Iowa that
was going to uh they went through
extensive training they were going to
arm Personnel not teachers but they were
going to arm Personnel they went through
extensive training with law enforcement
they they were actually putting more
round rounds down range than police
officers were the training was extensive
they had lock boxes they covered every
base it was amazing and then they
weren't able to do it because the
insurance company we have unfortunately
about One Insurance Company in the state
that that uh insures schools and they
said we won't insure you if you if you
have armed Personnel in the school and
so the legislature and I we're working
to try to address that and fix it we're
looking at school resource officers a
lot of other issues but absolutely
trained individuals that are trained
properly in a school that is your
absolute best line of defense and we're
working on trying to make that happen in
[Applause]
irowa
how you doing what's your name Jeremy so
we had to followup to the question so so
this is certainly I think the most
important issue we're facing with and
what we're seeing among kids I just
represents the corruption of our nation
and just the decay of where our
society's gone because you can predict
the future of a country just by looking
at the kids um this has been a hard
issue for me because over two years ago
we had an incident in a school district
where a teacher was stalked and murdered
by students and and the weapon was a
baseball bat um um I think what I want
to say is that this is a a much larger
pattern and the catastrophe in
Perry there's been a long a very growing
pattern of very violent Behavior so
there's a student at Ames beaten
unconscious a part of some strange race
baiting exercise where uh you know they
wanted the the autistic kid to say uh
the nword and then they wanted to beat
him unconscious and he had to leave the
school in an ambulance and I can only
imagine the trauma of a student having
to witness that and now the trauma that
student still being in the same building
with those kids who perpetrated that
horrific act of violence uh and it it
it's much more sever than just this
incident and armed security is a great
way to prevent the symptom from
manifesting but there's something much
much deeper going on in the hearts and
minds of our children where they're
willing to you know commit these
Psychopathic acts so it's it's a very
serious issue and it's much more
widespread than just these events this
is certainly a growing pattern the
pattern appear appears to be growing
worse and I'm truly frightened and I was
having a conversation yesterday with our
colleague representative Bowden about
these issues and I just wanted to get on
my knees and pray because we need as
much help as possible in navigating
these issues and giving our children uh
a life worth living and and the meaning
and the values uh so it's it's horrific
and yeah armed security is certainly a
great step in the right direction but we
need to go as deep as possible to help
these kids through whatever they're
suffering through that's good thank
you my name is Jeremy
my name is Jeremy hey um so VI I was
like I feel like this kind of goes along
with the last question I feel like
morale has been on a steep decline in
this country for quite a long time um I
feel like mental health kind of plays
into that and yeah kind of going with
the last question um I believe a big
reason for that is the American dream is
just getting farther and farther Out Of
Reach for a lot of us
um so so my question to you is will you
get foreign interests and corporate
interests out of real estate and if in
or if so how would you make that happen
sure I think with respect to China I
think it's a simple answer China's
buying up land in this country they
shouldn't any CCP affiliate should not
be buying land in the United States of
America then that's that's an easy
answer but I think there's something
deeper going on in this country there is
a sickness and I think that what
happened in Perry Iowa that's a symptom
of a deeper void in this country a void
of purpose and meaning and
identity and I'll be the first to say I
don't think US president can alone fill
that full void but I think we can fill
it partially with a national identity
that we lack right now we're hungry to
be part of something bigger than
ourselves yet we can't even answer what
it means to be an American today and I
think that's half the job of the next US
president actually we actually have had
some great policy discussions today but
I think half the job of the next US
president not a congressman or a senator
but the US president is to revive our
national character to answer who we
actually are As Americans to fill that
void of purpose and meaning with
something other than wokeism or
transgenderism or climatism or
cism otherwise it's same reason you see
depression anxiety fent
suicide gender
dysphoria these are symptoms of that
deeper void of purpose and
meaning and I do think part of the job
of the US president is to get out of the
way so that pastors and parents and
teachers and coaches across this country
can play their role too but I'm stepping
up and volunteering to play my part to
revive that missing national identity in
this country and yes you're right people
tend to be more proud of a country when
they're making more money in that
country I'm not this
guy they really wanted me to be the fake
Optimist the American dream is Alive and
Well I think that was actually literally
a line of one of the other presidential
candidates
but it's not it's alive and hanging on
for life support is where we are but I
think it can be well again and I think
that that's going to take simple
economic policies that at least Grease
the wheels for still filling that deeper
hunger we're using our taxpayer money to
pay people more to stay at home instead
of to go to work now I talked earlier
when di asked the question about
stimulating the economy that's bad for
the economy because that stops
businesses from growing and filling open
positions which is this top obstacle to
business growing but take the person
who's receiving the money do you think
it's actually good for them I mean My
Generation how old are you man if you
don't mind me asking I'm 42 4 we're in a
similar generation with a lot of us here
you know give or take
is we're the first generation ours that
the parents of our generation are
actually responsible still for the
financial sustenance of people our age
and younger for a majority of us that's
the first time that's happened you think
it's good for you to be in your parents
basement playing video game smok and pot
is that good is that actually good for
you again it's not compassion it's
almost a form of Cruelty driving
depression and anxiety and worse and so
that's where the economic malays and the
psychological malays of this country go
together and I do think it's going to
take a president with fresh legs coming
in from the outside seeing it as part of
our responsibility to address that
national identity prices to get this
right and I hope I'm up for the job I
think I am that's why we're doing this
thank you man usually around this time
is when we rep but I think if everyone's
cool with it will uh maybe another
another half an hour to give you more
time to answer questions I'd love to see
unemployment that you get a little and
then it it scales down and you after six
months it disappears unless you get a
job and then you actually get paid a
little bit more than when you weren't
working cuz we need to incentivize
people to take the job well we'll try
and get as many questions as we can in
and we'll do something that the cable TV
channels can't do and go long because we
can
I love that got some more questions a
lot of questions why is graphine the
best question for Ian why are you so
cool it's mostly your endorsement Ian
it's this cool uh shirt that Tim bought
me oh thanks Phil what's your name
Brad thank you I'm nervous too all right
don't worry you should you're fine um so
you good we're good I feel like you've
been grilled for a few hours so I was
going to do a question but I just want
to give the first part which is a
compliment um I'm continually impressed
with your poison strength as a media
seems to attack you I'm a combat veteran
of the Marine Corps and now I do
neurosurgery for a living I know I don't
look like it I have a sleeve tattoo but
I'll never get a job right uh in both my
careers people like you have made great
leaders so thank you thank you man I
appreciate that thank you thank
you thank you for your service to this
country as well SM man I appreciate it
what's your name Julie um I just wanted
to ask you your um opinion on all this
green energy stuff and the climate
change stuff because um honestly I don't
think the government should be telling
me you know what kind of stove I should
have and for some of us who live on a
lower income you know the burdens that
that kind of stuff would would cause
would be you know astronomical yes well
I'm going to say something that you're
not supposed to say even in the
Republican party but it's the truth the
climate change agenda is a
hoax and here's the Dirty Little Secret
has nothing to do with the
climate
what it has to do is I can almost at
least prove it to you very quickly the
very people who are most opposed to the
use of fosil fuels in the United States
are also the ones who are perfectly fine
shifting those same carbon emissions to
places like China in the name of
stopping global warming you can't
believe both those things at the same
time or the very people who are most
opposed to fossil fuels are among those
who are the most opposed as well to
nuclear energy in the United States
which is the greatest form of carbon
free energy production known know to
mankind again you can't believe both
those things at the same time if you're
applying principles of logic but if
you're subscribing to a quasi religious
cult I won't even call it a religion
because the religion has withstood the
test of time I would call this a cult
climate cult you can believe anything
you want and they even have their patron
saint uh modern what they view Jon of
Arc figure psychologically challenged
individual known as Greta thunberg who
they you know view as a modern Jon of
arch patron saint time figure it all the
qualities of religion flogging yourself
gas stove self-punishment engaging in
the equivalent of wearing a hair shirt
and flogging yourself many religions
across cultures Hinduism has a version
of this too is engaging in sort of
bodily discomfort and harm to substitute
for this
self-punishment that's kind of what the
climate religion is it has all of the
elements of a religion except not having
withstood the test of time which is why
I call it a cult now what am I going to
do about
it any mandate from the federal
government to even measure carbon
emissions is out the door I think we're
even measuring the wrong thing we should
be measuring human health economic
Mobility Prosperity rather than this one
arbitrary measure of carbon emissions
and the problem is when you start
measuring it you actually have something
that all four of us here are opposed to
is all kinds of strange things the
federal government starts doing like
subsidizing people to capture carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere build
pipelines buried in the ground you have
all sorts of strange things like
subsidizing electric vehicles I have no
problem with somebody choosing to buy an
electric vehicle because it looks cool
drives the way you want it to or
whatever reason you want to really just
don't expect me to pay for it which is
exactly what's happening today and by
the way if they can build a pipeline
across your backyard without your
consent to bury carbon dioxide in the
ground next up is your gas stove they'll
come in take it leave a $50 check in
your mailbox that's eminent domain for
you or take your cow or take your
combustion engine vehicle and so this is
a cult I think it's one of the greatest
threats that we face in the United
States of America to our sovereignty
today is the global climate cult and it
is shameful that I think it is outside
of the Overton window of even the
Republican party to actually talk about
it in the terms that I just did but we
have to see that if you think Co it's it
sort of has a similar pattern to it but
at least that came and went this one's
here to stay I think that was just the
practice round for the climate emergency
that's coming up and actually I'm suppos
been the most censored presidential
candidate according to this nonprofit
group but one time when my social media
account was outright locked it's only
happened FS was when I stated certain
hard facts about the climate movement
eight times as many people died last
year of cold temperatures rather than
warm ones the Earth is more covered by
Green surface area coverage today
because carbon dioxide is actually plant
food and the reality is 98% reduction in
the climate disaster death rate over the
last century the number of people who
die of climate related disasters for
every hundred who died in 1920 that
number is two today that's due to
advances powered by fossil fuels and so
that's the Inconvenient Truth for the
actual climate movement and it's going
to take a leader with the spine at the
top in the United States not to do the
waffle thing the the Republican thing to
do here is why are we moving so quickly
China's not doing stuff either I mean
these are sort of Nicki Haley type
talking points or even other Republicans
it doesn't matter that's a standard
Republican line on these on these
matters I think the right answer is
actually to start with the
truth this is not an existential risk to
humanity climate change has existed as
long as the Earth has existed and we
should not be focused on one metric of
carbon dioxide emissions when people are
dying more of bad climate change
policies than they are of climate change
itself and so the Humane thing to do is
to say no to this cult and yes to human
flourishing and growth regardless of the
carbon dioxide emissions that it results
in that's what I would say the carbon
itself is a very valuable asset set and
there's going to be a Mad Dash on the on
the air when people realize you can take
carbon dioxide out of the air turn it
into graphine you can take the methane
out of the air turn it into carbon
dioxide and then turn it into methane
turn it into graphine rather and then
use it as a building material uh and
there we've need a global Coalition so
that we don't pull too much of it out of
the air because people are going to
start harvesting that carbon dioxide uh
and I don't want to kill the trees like
you said it is Food For The Greenery so
we need to find some sort of mediative
stasis right on so I hope that addressed
your question yeah I have one more thing
I wanted to say I'm not from Iowa I've
been here volunteering I'm from Nebraska
but I wanted to say to everyone that is
from Iowa please caucus because it must
be exciting to be a part of all of this
and have candidates come we don't see
anyone in Nebraska unless you know
they're worried about that one uh
electoral vote that we might give to the
Democrats so we don't we don't have a
primary till May so if you are from Iowa
please please please caucus on the 15th
thank you and I I appreciate that I'm
going to use that as an opport
opportunity Tim I'd be remiss if I
didn't say it tonight but but I mean it
is every person's vote in the Iowa
caucus you could make the argument that
it's like the equivalent of a million
people in the impact that it has in
actually selecting the next US president
I laid it out earlier and so I don't to
rehash our earlier discussion I believe
we're being led by the system into a
trap right
now and I promise you I don't relish
this job but I'm here for a reason we've
done over 390 events in Iowa that's more
than all of the other candidates
combined I think by a multiple we're not
doing this for any reason other than the
fact that I think our country requires
like right now a leader who's actually
able to take our America first movement
to the next level and who is not the
subject of elimination in the in the
subject of an actively playing out plot
that we can see in straight eyes and so
I'm asking everybody in Iowa who is here
to do the right thing for our country on
January 15th and I'm asking you to
caucus for me and if you do I think
we're going to have a major surprise on
Monday and I think we're going to do
everything in our family's part and
we're going to succeed at it to make
sure that our country's best days are
actually not in some fake politician way
but in a true way actually still ahead
of us so thank you everybody who comes
out on Monday night to do that as well I
appreciate
it what's your name Elliott
hey Candace gentlemen I appreciate all
appreciate yall making it out here uh
braving the inclement weather um so I
got to the Marine Corps about a year ago
largely due to how the current
Administration handled as Ian so
correctly frames it our uh surrender in
Afghanistan as well as the way service
members were treated in regards to the
covid vaccine mandate and though I
appreciate your answer to the first
question Mr rabbas Swami as uh
commander-in-chief do you have any plans
as it relates to restoring Americans
trust in our military institutions and
do you intend on on holding military
leadership who implemented these
disastrous policies accountable yes and
I think the way we're going to restore
trust isn't by fake jingoism it's by
actually acknowledging the failures and
instituting accountability for those
failures comes on a couple of levels
first is generations of Foreign Wars
that have not Advanced our interests 7
trillion of our national debt owed to
the wars in both Iraq and Afghanistan
that palpably could just look at the
results 20 years later for God's sake
the is still in charge 20 years later
Iraq is a more broken country than we
showed up sending tens of thousands to
about 15,000 of America's Sons and
Daughters lives sacrificed in those two
Wars adding 7 trillion to our national
debt so yes I do I do hold accountable
the bipartisan foreign policy
establishment some of whom are back ated
again available on the Republican KCK
ticket to be voted for for US president
to be trotted back and to bring back a
dick chainy vision for our foreign
policy that should be relegated to the
dustbins of History so yes we need to
accountability I think we also need
accountability in the nearer term for
the self-hatred that our own military is
perpetuating in our own ranks and
there's a connection between these two
I'm referring to the rise of sort of the
woke infection in our US military ranks
these are not two separate issues what
happened is that General Mark Millies of
the
world wanted to deflect the left-wing
criticism keep in mind it was generally
a republican idea to favor the rock war
the left used to hit him for that to say
okay well we'll just say the magic words
systemic racism white rage whatever you
want us to say but go away we'll blow
the woke smoke to deflect accountability
for the institutional failure of the
military itself how do we get this right
restore the true purpose of the US
military what is it to win Wars to
actually avoid Wars through being strong
in protecting our own Homeland right
here at home which is more vulnerable
than it has ever been so I believe that
the top purpose of the US military
should be to protect Americans against
threats make our national defense
spending directed towards our own
National Defense that includes cyber
attacks super EMP attacks that could
take out our electric grid in a matter
of days that we're more vulnerable to
now than ever we I do view it as an
invasion on our own Southern border and
I believe an outward facing function for
our US military at our border as we
talked about earlier is an appropriate
use of our military and that's how we
restore trust I think people would be
happy to serve this country if they knew
it was actually to serve Americans
rather than to fight somebody else's War
halfway around the world so some
Ukrainian kleptocrat can buy a bigger
house that's not going to happen on my
watch and that think that's how we
restore trust thank
you is a porva here in my wife
she if a porva is here bring her up at
some point she's GNA come she's putting
the kids to bed but she wanted to make
it for the end of this so shout out to
aova the generator what's your name Alex
all right uh nice to see everybody here
big fan of the show big fan of you vake
um
so in uh primary schools in Russia they
currently teach their students uh jabin
across before they ever teach a hook for
two years uh in China they have
masculinity training for their young men
um if you look at the Obesity rates in
America we have been we've done a severe
disservice to our youth in physical
education uh where traditionally you
look at like the de laa program out in
California back in the 1930s we were
going to go a certain direction and then
we flipped to another where kids can
just you know opt out of PE uh what can
you do to help make uh America's youth
strong as president of the United States
yeah you know I think that let's put
aside the presidential Authority here I
think that a lot of this should be
driven by the states I'm a
constitutionalist I believe that which
is not reserved to the federal
government is reserved respectively to
the states and to the people and I
believe that cuz they're not my not my
words they're the words in our
constitution in our 10th Amendment but
let's just talk about the broad policy
I've actually just as a citizen
advocated often for the SAT standardized
testing I think you have verbal and math
they added a writing section I think
it's not bad to bring back a physical
fitness section as well just measure it
different institutions can put different
weight on what they want to wait it in
not all students not all schools should
weigh the math scores the same way as
the weigh the reading score as the same
way they weigh the writing scores the
same way they weigh the physical fitness
score
but I think we should make it something
worth aspiring to in this country so
that avoids any kind of mandating or
anything like that as a basic First Step
just signifying we're measuring
something because it's worth measuring
carbon emissions not worth measuring
physical fitness and young people worth
measuring right and so so the things
that you actually measure are the things
that actually presumably matter we used
to have the Presidential Fitness Test it
was actually under I think it was
President Obama and it might have been a
little bit of a pet project of Michelle
Obama for whatever reason to eliminate
the Presidential Fitness Test that's not
what it sounds like in the context of me
saying it of the US president though we
could determine the I think it doesn't
hurt for a president to disclose how
many push-ups and pull-ups they could do
too it doesn't hurt but that's not what
I'm talking about it refers to the
Presidential Fitness Test in junior high
school that refers to a number of
attributes of how you're able to perform
on basic parameters of physical fitness
that allows us to hold our system
accountable and teachers accountable and
schools accountable for how well we're
doing on on that metric just as well as
how well or these days how poorly we're
doing on the metrics of math or reading
proficiency so I think that measuring it
alone and making that a norm in this
country would be a free non-cost
enhancing non- Liberty infringing way of
actually doing what I think is good and
important for our country and oddly
enough I don't think it's that odd
actually that's going to have a palpable
impact for the better on the mental
health epidemic in this country actually
a lot of young kids are going to be
mentally and psychologically a lot
better off if we actually start just
measuring and aspiring towards improved
levels of physical fitness as well I
think most of us most of us know that
intuitively it's definitely true from a
data perspective as well so that'd be my
answer to your question and I do think
I've already been talking about it
people have asked me why is this guy
you're running for president what does
this have to do with it well what it has
to do with it is it still relates to
that root cause and that loss of purpose
in our country and I do think that
measuring physical fitness is strictly a
good step for our youth and including
integrated into our schools and
standardized testing thank thank you man
app what's your name Ryan Ryan hey Ryan
there you go um so I've followed your
campaign um since basically the
beginning and uh I love your message I
think you could fix this country um
we've seen what they've done going after
Donald Trump um
indictments uh even trying to remove him
from the ballot in certain States my
question is how do I vote for V
ramaswami without sending the message
that I am okay with what with what they
are doing to Donald
Trump I think your question weighs on
the lot minds of a lot of people I met
today what I saw in many of the rooms I
was in was a sense of struggle with that
question of loyalty and I think our
loyalty my loyalty and I know Donald
Trump's loyalty and the Loyalty of the
people participating in this caucus
process is to this country so the
question is what's right for the country
let's just agree with that whoever
you're going to vote for that's what
matters here not loyalty to me not
loyalty to Trump it's loyalty to the
United States of
America I think you have a if you want
to I'm going to be blunt about this I
think if you want to save Trump and save
this country a vote for me is actually
the way to go what they're doing to
Donald Trump is wrong I have stood up
against it at every step of this process
to the point of derision to the point of
people have there's I mean people have
had all kinds of conspiracy theories
about me but one of them and more
popular ones is there's some kind of
trump plant that Trump and I had some
kind of deal early on in this campaign
to somehow eliminate Ronda santis as
though this was a worthy goal for a guy
who's got other things to do in life
than to focus on eliminating Ronda
santis from contention no that was
ridiculous but I'm saying that I've been
so strongly supportive of Donald Trump
in the face of these prosecut that even
many people circulated nonsense like
this I've stood up against I went to the
Miami Courthouse I've stood up against
these persecutions for God's sake I have
actually written a Foya demand and
submitted it Freedom of Information Act
request to know what Biden told Jack
Smith what mer Garland told Jack Smith
followed through on that taking legal
steps and I hope we get
accountability I think that we weren't I
wasn't planning on announcing this
tonight but might as well just say it I
think tomorrow morning if not by noon by
tomorrow morning in the next 48 hours
I am submitting an amicus brief to the
Supreme Court arguing for why they need
to overturn Colorado's disastrous
decision to try to keep Donald Trump off
the ballot because it's the right thing
to do for this
country and as somebody who's been
trained in the law I feel like a sense
of obligation to do that or somebody who
understands the Constitution i' it's my
belief that every other Republican
myself included needs to withdraw from
any ballot that forcibly withdraws
Donald Trump from the primary ballot
because that's how you actually stop the
Brazen election interference in our own
primary if every other Republican
nullifies Maine then it has no impact so
that's the length to which I've gone and
so people know this about me when I'm
saying this at this point it is my firm
conviction that this system which has
ratcheted up the threat level one by one
to eliminating Donald Trump from the
ballot will stop at
nothing I I'm increasingly certain it's
will stop at nothing to keep this man
away from the white house so I think the
best way to literally save Trump is to
at least have arguably somebody the
system might actually even some elements
of it prefer less than Donald Trump for
what I'm bringing to Washington DC and I
think that's also what this country
requires I think they duped him at many
steps they told him you can't fire those
Civil Service bureaucrats because of
so-called Civil Service protections read
the law those civil service protections
do not apply to mass firings Mass
firings are what I'm bringing to the DC
bureaucracy so I will honor the man and
I have and I think it's the right thing
to do and I will do it as the next
president because he kept us out of
Foreign Wars that didn't Advance our
interests and he grew this economy those
are no too small
accomplishments but our America First
agenda does not belong to Donald Trump
just as it doesn't belong to me or
anybody else up here it belongs to you
to us to We the People of this country
and we owe it to this country to make
sure that movement does not end with
Donald Trump which is what the system
has set up to do I believe we're being
led into a trap right now and it pains
me to watch it so I'm asking you to do
the right thing for this country if you
want to support Donald Trump even or
what he represents is actually more
precise the right way to do that to see
this through for the country is a vote
for me in this Iowa caucus on Monday and
I think people are there's an emotional
component to this
I actually think we need to vote with
our brains there's times when you vote
with your heart there's times when you
vote with your
brain your heart can get you to the
doorstep of why America First matters
but now voting with your brain is asking
are you going to look back here's the
thought experiment that I'd like for
every voter in this state to go through
and I think a lot of them are
considering myself for Trump heading
into
Monday do you think you're going to look
back a year from now and say whatever
God forbid happens this year say we were
shocked Ed by what happened I mean last
time it was a man-made pandemic and a
tech rigged process leading up to an
election that we all know was absolutely
an unfair
election that was last
time what do you think they're going to
do this time are you going to be shocked
next January and say oh I was shocked
that that happened or are you going to
say we should have seen that coming and
I think it's exactly going to play out
if it's not me in the nomination slot
it's going to play out exactly the way I
laid out it's going to be Trump in a two
horse r
versus a puppet who they can control one
way or another they're going to
eliminate him we're going to look back
and say that should have been obvious
when in fact right now people are
behaving as though it's not and we're
going to regret the result and I don't
think there's a good chance I don't
think we have a country left not the
same country that we know and love and
so we owe it to this country and to our
founding fathers to make sure the 250
year experiment does not end this year
and that we have yet another 250 years
and then some left to go that's why I'm
asking you to vote for me if you want to
save Trump and save this country vote
for me and I hope hope that gets you to
the place where you make the right
decision for this country thank you man
I think we have enough time for two more
yeah good two more
questions what's your name Tim Tim good
name it's a great name it's okay hi my
name is Simmon and uh I have a question
about civic duty voting uh I'm trying to
get my friend to get on the uh the V
train but uh he he likes a lot of the
most of your things except for civic
duty voting and so I have uh his concern
concerns he uh just doesn't think it has
a point to it uh young adults uh voting
there's no other way to get Young
Americans to vote besides making it
harder the test will only hurt the
Americans who don't have access to good
education or resources so poor
communities is what he said also you're
an adult at 18 you can be Tried by Court
you can go into the workforce and be a
part of the community you should be
allowed to vote without taking a test
like an American citizen is what his
concerns are cool so thank what I would
tell your friend is first of
all I I'm saying this in a in a friendly
way relax in the sense that this this
anything touching this would require a
constitutional amendment but why don't
you why don't we talk about forgetting
the plumbing of how we accomplish it
let's at least see if we agree on the
spirit of it which is that in order to
be a full citizen of a country and
citizenship is not about what you get
it's actually about what you give women
didn't have citizens
didn't have voting rights in this
country people think it means what do
you get you get the right to vote no
women were citizens all along didn't
have the right to vote so if you
actually Trace our history what's the
origin of citizenship citizenship is
about Allegiance it's about Duty it's
actually why I don't believe that dual
citizenship is a coherent Concept in the
United States it's all about or about
any country it's about Allegiance it's
about and with Allegiance comes a duty
so with that said the basic point I was
making is what's your basic duty at
least we should expect of someone to a
country some people will make cases for
mandatory military service I don't but I
think the basic table Stakes of your
duty to this country should be to know
the bare minimums about this country and
the Constitution and our history it's
mainly just the Constitution and the way
the government works and we know that we
that's an intuition we already track
because if you're an immigrant to this
country we say you can't vote you can
have all kinds of other benefits we give
all kinds of benefits to illegal
immigrants to this country there's all
kinds of things we do but at least when
things have work the way they're
supposed to you can't vote in this
country until you become a naturalized
citizen which requires you to pass a
basic Civics test and so if we require
that of a legal immigrant to this
country before they cast a ballot at The
Ballot Box I think it's reasonable for
every High School senior who graduates
from high school to at least know the
bare minimums about the country that
every immigrant has to know as a
condition for becoming a voting citizen
of this country before the age of 25 I
think it's a reasonable thing to ask now
if you've had life experience as an
adult I'm willing to drop it if you say
that you've served in a military or
first respond role great that's a
different way of having a legiance or
service to a country but the bare
minimums so so nobody has to take a
Civics test there but the bare minimums
are to say that you have some knowledge
of the country of which you're a citizen
I was here in Iowa and so this actually
generated a lot of controversy my
campaign staff hated me for rolling out
this idea because it didn't pull well
they the whole I I Saida they said well
at least can we can we pull it I said
yeah I'd love to see the data it did not
pull well I came back and I still rolled
it out in the speech where I was
planning to because I think it's the
right thing for the country so I'm aware
that that it has not been a friend to my
vote Gathering process in this
campaign but I think people have come
around to it actually over the course of
the
Year some of my other positions have had
the benefit of this too my position on
Ukraine or otherwise but in this one it
so happens I think people have come
around to it a 10-year-old girl in Iowa
her name is Lena she came to one of my
events having heard about this
controversy she heard me take a beating
from it from mostly on the left they
claimed it was Jim Crow or something
like this everything's Jim Crow If
You're 10-year-old and somebody says Jim
Crow I think you might think it like
refers to air just it permeates and it's
everywhere but anyway she heard a lot of
this criticism and she printed out the
100 question Civics test most adults in
the United States would fail it if they
took it right now 60% is a passing score
she's 10 years old she comes up with a
print out with a handwritten note
showing me and telling me that she got
100% 100 out of under to the age of 10
so I don't think this is something that
results in some socioeconomic struggle
if this 10-year-old girl in Iowa can
know the first thing and questions like
how many branches of government are
there what branch of government does the
US president lead I don't think it's too
much to ask an 18-year-old to know what
branch of government the US president
leads before they show up at The Ballot
Box to cast a vote for the US president
I think that's a reasonable thing to ask
of a country and and I think that that's
what it means to be a citizen of this
one so to tell your friend to look at
the Spirit of that and don't worry about
the plumbing so so much thank
you what's your name hi I'm Britney um
big fan of Tim Cass big fan of Candace
hello hi um okay so V thank you so much
for being here I know the weather is not
ideal right now but thank you for being
here um my so your slogan has been truth
and it's all over this room um many
Americans over the years have felt lied
to by our government and that they have
pulled the wool over our eyes with so
many occurrences in history especially
in the last four years recently you have
been speaking what recently happened
with January 6th and you're constantly
be getting attacked so thank you for
speaking the truth on that thank you um
there have been many there have been so
many whistleblowers such as Snowden to
expose the truth to the American people
about what is going on behind closed
doors my question to you is do you have
it on your radar to Grant pardons to
those who told the truth to the American
people and also to release a documents
that would uncover a lot of unknowns to
the American people or to provide
protections to Future whistleblowers
yes yes and yes is the answers to your
questions I mean I think
that so our pardon be a clemency
but I think that if you swear an oath to
the Constitution your job is to keep it
and so you cannot
systematically participate in the
violation of those constitutional
freedoms and constitutional rights
without exposing that to the public and
I think we the people deserve a
government that just tells the people
the truth again
not just when it's easy but when it's
hard sometimes it's ugly that's when we
need it the most and I think we've been
systematically lied to you could just go
to the last eight years seven eight
years Trump Russia collusion hoax made
up Co origin couldn't say that it came
from a lab in China when it was obvious
that it likely came from Lab in China
now that we know that it did how our
money is being spent in Ukraine right
now the truth about what happened on
January 6 the truth about the Nashville
transgender shooter Manifesto so where
you know we actually went down to
Nashville cace and I didn't event there
together calling on the local police or
the FBI either one to just release that
Manifesto and how we were actually lied
to even in that Community they said
there's a lot in there that it's not
what you think it is but it could be
dangerous to release then it gets
released and we see it was just actually
a race baiting psychologically
challenged
person a government that has
systematically lied to its people the
reason people don't trust the government
is that the government doesn't trust the
people trust is a two-way relationship
actually
and so I think the two ways we rebuild
trust in this
country with the event last night did
you yeah you were you were all the way
you both you were there for the press
press Gaggle afterwards that was a fun
press Gaggle we had last night people
should watch that one it was the longest
one I've done in a long time we do the
events and the Press will come up
afterwards it's about 35
minutes I think we want to rebuild trust
in this country if two things happen I
think we have taken a Quantum Leap for
we're on we're we're back on track as a
country they're easy to do the president
of the United States tells the American
people what we know about the subjects
where the government has lied to the
people uaps tell us the truth what
happened on January 6th just tell us the
truth what was Saudi Arabia's role in
9/11 they we know we'd lie to us just
tell us the truth just go straight down
the list what was what was or wasn't
known about the weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq just tell us the
truth how many times as a government
official we saw the Twitter files any
time a government official has pressured
a private actor or a company or a bank
or a tech company to do something the
government couldn't do directly just
publish it as a first step tell us the
truth was our taxpayer money used to
fund the gain of function research that
resulted in the origin of the co9
pandemic that's the first thing that
it's up to a US president to do from the
standpoint of the government and then if
just one person in the
media just one I I don't need NBC and
ABC and CBS and CNN and everybody else
doing at the same time just just one of
them look Their audience in the eye and
tell them when it came to the hunter
Biden laptop story that was suppressed
on the eve of the last election when it
came to the Trump Russia collusion hoax
when it came to the origin of covid-19
when it came to the truth of the
totality at least even of what happened
on January 6th or the Gretchen Whitmer
kidnapping plot or
whatever we didn't tell you the whole
truth we're sorry about it here's why we
didn't these are institutional failures
and here's why we're going to make sure
that never happens
again and I know you're still not going
to trust us
tomorrow but we hope to re earn your
trust by repeatedly telling you the
truth transparently and we regret what
happened and we fired the people who
were accountable for hiding it from you
if you have a president who does that
from the White House and just one not
not all of them just one actor in The
mainstream media who does that looking
Their audience in the eye on a TV screen
and telling them the same thing we are
well on our way to reuniting and
Reviving this country
if I'm your president that's going to
happen from the
presidency and I think there's probably
at least one good enterprising smart
person still left there in the
mainstream media that could step up and
do the same thing and if those two
things happen I am confident that we
don't have to be mired in this divisive
decline that we're in but that we still
can be in our Ascent I believe that and
I'm going to do my part and I hope those
in the media who who have failed have
step up and do their part
and you know all I'm going to ask is of
the citizens of this country to do your
part here in Iowa starting on Monday and
that's what gets us there so thank you I
appreciate you asking the question I
sometimes I think that it's more
valuable to lie to the people and and
it's actually better in that we're
talking about like secret weapons
programs you mention uaps if we're
working on like the atom bomb they
didn't want to come out and be like by
the way Germany and everyone listening
we're building an atom bomb they didn't
they were like are you building a Adam
bom no we are not building an ad so so
there's times that you want to blatantly
lie and not even like say that the thing
is not existent so so I I disagree about
the distinction between secrecy versus
lying are the certain State Secrets they
need to be State Secrets yes
systematically lying when asked about it
I think is a different matter and so I
think that's that's a hard line to draw
but it but you and I would still agree
that at a certain point you have a
government that still tells the truth to
the people again and I think we deserve
to know the truth of all the way what
happened to I mean what's the truth of
what happened with JFK I think we should
know I mean I think the public should
know we've been non-transparent about it
every step of the way people call me
conspiracy theorists for asking the
question that's not the point the point
is the government just deserves to at a
certain point in time tell the people
the truth again and I disagree with you
even in the near term in the short run
it could be an in it could be a more
convenient thing to do to lie to the
people but in the long run I think the
answer is always to actually stand for
the truth and if you get into the
specifics even of
geopolitics this relates to the
historical neocon neoliberal view of
strategic ambiguity right so
non-transparency at home goes hand in
glove with the foreign policy worldview
of strategic ambiguity it's a whole
worldview that says you're going to
actually be in a stronger position if
you don't tell people what you're going
to do actually view it the other way I
think that if we have clear red lines
and actually say that you know what we
are nuclear equipped and here's where we
are that's actually going to if we tell
a country that if you cross this red
line we're actually going to have major
conf consquences to pay for it that's
more likely to actually avoid war than
it is to actually engage in strategic
ambiguity and so it's just a totally
different worldview from the traditional
neoconservative neoliberal Vision that
I'm bringing which is transparency at
home which actually translates to you
don't need the National Security charade
if your whole foreign policy strategy
was also grounded in truth in actually
saying that this is what we're okay with
and this is what we are affirmatively
not okay with and here are the
conditions under which we will blow you
to annihilation because we have to and
if you cross that red line we follow
through and do it but the rest of the
time we're not going to pretend like
that's a possibility either and so it's
a total alternative world view all the
way up and all the way down but it is
grounded in yes absolute truth and
transparency and so that's what I'm
going to bring and if you think that
that's dangerous if you think that that
poses risks to the future of our
Republic then I'm not your guy I'm not
your candidate but if you believe with
me that in the long run this is the way
to respect the founding ideals of this
country and to lead a country that is
stronger over the long run for relying
on Truth both in our foreign policy and
our domestic policy then I don't think
there's anybody in this race who comes
close to being able to deliver that in
the way that I will so that's what
that's what I offer I want to thank uh
VI for having us out and for everyone
else here joined and has has hung out
with us we've got uh a special members
only segment VIP we're going to be
hanging out at this private party
keeping the conversation going going for
a little bit while longer so head over
to timcast.net
can on the best political shirts.com the
phrase that I'm wearing right now was
actually highlighted by Politico and
they were actually uh showing a picture
of my hat but they conflated this issue
with uh conspiracy theories and what
happened with Jeffrey Epstein is not a
conspiracy theory it's a conspiracy fact
Independent Media has been talking about
it for many years now while the
corporate prostitute hor stream media
has literally been covering it up shame
on them criminal actions by these sobs
that deserve to of course
be recalled fight back spread the word
wear the shirts the best political
shirts.com is the best way to support me
and uh even though uh Vic uh you want to
Peg the fed and I want to End the Fed
thank you so much for coming here and
being a part of and Tak and taking
questions that are not scripted uh we're
actually going to continue the
conversation on also the best political
show.com where we are going to have you
as a guest soon as well so I look
forward to that as well thank you so
much thank you man yeah I'm uh Ian
crossin if you don't know what's
happening guys follow Med and uh take
care of yourself your your stomach and
your heart and your brain kind of reduce
the acidity um let the let the oils flow
through you and get in touch with God
that way it helps pretty good so Now's
the Time to start eating healthy and do
a plank do like a 30- second plank or
something too no seed oil graphine no no
graphine and then we'll talk about
graphine Ian it's been it's been a
pleasure to sit next to
you guys you know where to find me me
you can subscribe to my YouTube channel
also just want to reention the series of
shot in the darkk for people that are
interested in learning more about
vaccines in big Pharma I think it's the
most important work that I do and I just
want to say it's a tremendous honor to
be on the road with aake this week we're
going to be hitting a bunch of campaign
stops tomorrow um just love his vision
for the future so just as much as I can
throw power to him I just I'm I'm really
impressed with your campaign thank you I
appreciate it K thank you close us out
yeah
well look I
I'm Guided by my gratitude to this
country actually I am not I don't covet
the Office of the President and if
there's somebody else who can step up
and do this job better that I can they
will have my support and I full optimism
for the country but I do think we're in
the middle of a kind of war in this
country right now and I don't use that
word lightly I don't think it is a war
between black and white as the media
would have you
believe I don't even think it's a war
between Democrat and Republican for some
of the reasons we've talked about here I
think it's a war between those of us who
love the United States of America and
our founding ideals and a fringe
minority who hates this country and what
we stand for it's a war between the
permanent State and the everyday
Citizen and I think we need right now
more than ever a commanderin-chief a
general who's actually going to lead us
to victory in the war I think you got to
know you're in a war to win can't be
asleep at the switch I think you can't
be bought and paid for by that existing
system every politician's dancing to the
tune their biggest donor my biggest
donor is me I don't report to them I
report to you the people of the
country but I think now more than ever
it's also going to require somebody with
fresh
legs and I think somebody from the Next
Generation to reach and lead the next
generation of Americans and so if you
agree with me on
that I'm going to ask you to vote for me
starting in Iowa on January 15th it's
going to be a cold night told it's
likeus 12 cold no no no- 22- 22 cold
well yes I think that I think that this
could actually be for the people who
want to support me to be the next
president you know what George
Washington I don't think complained
about the weather when he crossed the
Delaware either and I think we're in
we're in a 17 19 76 moment I think we
are in a war for the future of our
country so despite it being cold I'm
going to ask the people starting right
here in
Iowa to safely bundle up be warm but
come out on the night of the Iowa caucus
do the right thing for this country and
if you Circle my name that night I think
we have a good shot at winning the Iowa
caucus and if I win the Iowa caucus I'm
your next president and if I'm your next
president we get done the things I'm
telling you we will get done and I am
confident that our best days are
actually still going to be ahead of us
so thank you guys for having me thank
you everybody for hanging out and
watching this show and we'll be back
tomorrow we'll see yall
[Applause]
then